this is Jocko podcast number 167 with
echo Charles and me Jocko Willick good
evening echo good evening beware of that
trap choose dear Beowulf the better part
eternal rewards do not give way to pride
for a brief while your strength is in
bloom but it fades quickly and soon
there will follow illness or the sword
to lay you low or a sudden fire or surge
of water or jabbing blade or javelin
from the air or repellant age your
piercing eye will dim and darken and
death will arrive
dear warrior to sweep you away and that
right there is some timeless wisdom
offered by the the epic poem Beowulf the
first poem in the English language of
course it's Old English which is
mutually unintelligible from the modern
English that we speak but it has some
incredible translations if you want to
read it
I recommend the Seamus Heaney version
but regardless of the translation
translation that you get the story
remains as do of the lessons lessons
based on the war and leadership and
really human nature then we find these
lessons over and over and over again
throughout history and in different
cultures and in different Wars and
we all continue to learn everyday from
history and from each other and it
certainly seems that there are some
principles that are universal there are
some underlying unifying theories that
bind together and thread through
leadership and war and human nature and
the more we experience in life the more
clearly we can see the thread of these
unifying theories I am tonight I happen
to have on the podcast an individual
with a lot of experience experience in
war experience in leadership and
experience in life and he also happens
to be someone that I grew up with in the
SEAL Teams who is a great friend and who
just retired a couple days ago as a seal
Master Chief my friend and my brother by
the name of Jason Gardner Jason Jaco
thanks for coming on man hey I'm really
excited to be here and um it's kind of
cool because I know that you listen to
the podcasts and you were one of the
first guys that reached out to me I
don't know what number podcast it was
but you reached out to me really early
and said hey this is kick-ass man keep
doing it and then you know as the
podcast kind of spread I started hearing
from more guys but that was a pretty you
were that literally the first guy that
reached out to me and said bro
keep it going and I said cool Wilco
that's awesome yeah and like iris is the
one that said told me hey Jacko's got a
podcast and I'm like oh okay she goes
you don't know how to listen to podcasts
tearfully I said no gave her my phone
she got it set up it was episode six and
within a week and a half
because of my commute I was caught up
and then just dialed in from there on
out and talking about it sharing it with
a lot of other guys and it's been a huge
help to me that's awesome and yeah if
anyone hasn't put this together yet this
is iris a gardeners husband and iris is
on podcast number 70 mm-hmm
so if you want to listen to that you can
hear us talk about you I guessed
indirectly because you were still active
duty in the tameless so all right let's
get to your story let's talk about you
okay where'd you grow up my dad was in
the Marine Corps so we moved around a
little bit kind of settled down up in
San Clemente here in Orange County grew
up up there swam played water polo did
that through high school and then yeah I
think started doing a martial art Clark
College attempt on one of the
instructors was a team guy in Vietnam
order and at it back in the day you know
I had no one knew what seals were and
then my parents had found out that that
he was a seal in Vietnam and they're
like oh you know this guy was a sealing
I'm like what is that and they said
these guys are awesome it's really hard
training their water warriors which was
super appealing growing up at the beach
and water polo and swimming so then I
just latched on to that and that's what
what I got after and enlisted right out
after high school so was your dad was
your dad kind of like the stereotypical
marine that was just like oh no like
acting like a drill starter charging no
my dad my dad was super laid back easy
just an easygoing good guy and he was a
Jag officer in the Marine Corps so he
was like an attorney but but not
definitely not your stereotypical marine
and at one point I was thinking about
going the marine corps and he talked me
out of it
don't do it don't do it and he's like
hey the Navy the SEAL team just closed
loops or you could go to recon but at
the time it wasn't closed loose so you'd
go in and out in and out he goes you
don't want to do that you want to do
this and then yeah the nor'easter now
has MARSOC which you can just go in and
you can be a Special Operations guide
your whole career
what is closed-loop what are the meaning
so what I just said about the Marine
Corps looked like now you can go in the
Marine Corps and you can just be in
Special Operations for your whole career
before you could go for what would how
long of a tour where they do two or
three deployments at a I think there's
like a three-year tour or six years they
would do to come in and then it'd have
to go somewhere else they might go back
to an infantry unit or something like
that and that's called like a open yeah
open loop meaning that you don't
necessarily stay in a job and you want
the whole time okay now at what point
did you start listening to heavy metal
punk rock and hardcore music cuz I know
that's the first like connection you and
I had which I don't know is there some
weird sort of thing when you just like
look at some other guy you know this
guy's into hardcore I I mean it's not
it's not like I walked up and said hey
what kind of music do you like no it was
just like immediate do you just know
right yeah it I don't know what the bona
fides are absolutely on that um yeah
shoot I explored around with like a lot
of different music and it just wasn't
enough you know it's like oh okay well
I'll listen to the doors yeah stray cats
I like them for a little bit man then
the and it was kind of an investment to
buy an album back in those days or to
find even any punk rock so I found I
think like a Dead Kennedys album fresh
fruit for rotting vegetables that was
kind of like my gateway drug and then
I'm like oh okay this is really getting
me moving yeah then I remember I think I
was 14 or 15 when I went to my first
show up in UC Irvine it was like PIL
which was Johnny Ron's band and I I saw
I you know and in a mosh pit
was just like what is this yeah
I want to live here I want to get a
mailbox right outside this thing and
just stay in here at this point of
friction circle and around and around
forever and I was like boom then that
was it and you know discovered GBH and
an Orange County had a really really
like probably a one of the biggest
scenes in the world at the time for all
the music that would come through there
or was going out of there so GBH the DI
uniform choice which was guys that I
glommed in later in high school
those guys were awesome and and you knew
the guys from uniform no I don't but I
really liked their music and I liked
their message because some of the other
stuff like okay Rage Against the Machine
for instance I like the music like I
just can't get behind the lyrics yeah
you know or cro-mags that was a great
example yeah love the music and I like
the lyrics do it because it's good like
get after it stuff so and then there
just may be that that buzzing I don't
know what guys did in other wars when
for sure no good music - going into
combat listening to kill them all
instead of listening to Puff the Magic
Dragon right that's literally what's
what Americans were listening to like
they're listening to Puff the Magic
Dragon and those folk music bombs and I
mean I guess maybe at the outside edge
somebody might have been listening to
Hendrix or something that was a little
harder yeah but yeah yeah it's me
there's a there's a this is just
straight-up the way it is some human
beings I would say normally boys have
this thing in their head that wants to
fight and like wants to break things
yeah and and and when you hear your
example the doors your you're like okay
well this is you know you hear light my
fire and you're okay look I'm kind of
I'm feeling a little something there and
then you hear the crow max and you go
okay you hear Motorhead and you go oh
okay this is this is me this is one
right here this is uh I completely
understand this music right now
yeah and Annette just and they can use
pick it up and other people yeah yeah
and then so that and then like I stuck
with punk rock for a long time and then
a buddy of mine in high school who I
swam with Steve Rosenthal is like hey
you should check out Metallica oh yeah
yeah and then they were like they
crossed me over to where I'm like oh no
now I like speed metal too and then
finally I found my way to Slayer and
kind of stuck with them forever and it's
layers on a continual loop in the back
of my head all the time and it's always
surfacing up or down um but now it's
like really by exception that I listen
to it because I just can't listen to it
all day I got fired up but still really
good yeah it is
and so then you enlist in the Navy
mm-hmm you go to buzz and this time what
you weight yours it I won in 87 and then
went up to Great Lakes did Gunner's Mate
a school up there and so I think I
checked into bud sometime in May or June
88 and how prepared were you for buds
cuz it you know a lot of people that
listen to this
will think they want to go to buds or
whatever and they're paranoid about what
they can do to prepare and I know I'm
assuming you probably did something
similar why did cuz we had no idea what
was going on had no idea what the
training was like the video you probably
watch the same video as me if they even
had that video there's no one special
yeah so he watched it be someone special
and you think well in order to get ready
for the SEAL Teams what I need to do is
look cool yeah we're all black yeah and
be cool but there was no hey here's the
protocol to get good at pull-ups here's
the protocol to get good at swimming
with fins none of that no no and then
you know like in boot camp I have found
that we actually got out of shape me and
there's another guy in in my bootcamp
class that actually just retired as a
master chief as well and we would go in
the bathroom and do pull-ups in on the
stalls just to try and stay in shape
um one thing I didn't do enough is run
so I hated running and then I was in
every goon squad until I think third
phase then it clicked and I was already
a really good swimmer so the water
wasn't an issue for me but I was just
hammered and a goon squad you know it's
when you're towards the back of the deal
and and they're like okay you guys are
done you're doing this run the rest of
you start doing push-ups hit the surf
and they just mess with you forever
feel like the first all through first
base every time to run I threw up
because I was gonna I was like inches in
front of failings
yeah and just had to reach deep and and
push push it across the finish line you
said there were some what happened it
sank we you were telling me the other
day about something happened saying oh
what was that so think before you
started training in a pre training they
said hey we need volunteers to come out
to San Clemente Island to help out with
the class that was was out there and you
just kind of go and work behind the
scenes with the staff out there at San
Clemente Island and so I think like the
second night I was out there we were in
Chow and instructors and students are
eating in the same room as this little
Quonset hut and they had it was taco
night and so there's a big sign up there
when you went went up to get served like
hey only two tacos so when I got up
there the cook is like there was only
one taco left he goes hey just come back
when I'm making some more come back up
here and get one so I ate my one taco
went back up to get my next one he's
like here you go and as I'm walking with
my tray back one of the instructors says
to me hey didn't you already ate two
tacos and I'm like oh my goodness I
didn't know what to do so I said no and
then I tried to keep going well it was
the phase officer you know he wasn't
wearing any rank insignia so then all
the other instructors leap up they're
all huge and they just start screaming
at me and I'm thinking to myself are
I've already ruined it we're done
so I got an even eat the taco I just got
out of there and I went back to where
you know our little hot where we were
sleeping and I just went to bed it was
like at 5:00 p.m. because I was like oh
no then the next morning at 4:00 a.m.
there's a knock on the door and one of
the guys opens up the door and it's one
of the students that's actually in the
class and he goes hey is there a
gardener in here and then everyone just
looks at me you know and I'm like yeah
I'm back here and they go they wants you
down at the beach so I got dressed and
went down there you know I feel like I'm
going to Castle Dracula I'm like oh what
are they gonna do to me so the
instructors are all circled up and the
phase officers there he goes gardener
get over here so I go over there and he
goes he hands me a thermometer and he
goes we need to get the water temp so
you're gonna go out in the water up to
your waist and you're gonna stay there
and do not you I need you to go all the
way to your waist and you're gonna stay
there for two minutes
don't come in early and I'm like ooh yah
so I take it and I just go I go out
until I'm just treading water but as I
see how this is gonna go right so then
and I didn't even look at my watch I
just stayed there until finally they're
like get in here dummy running in and
hand him the thermometer and they check
it was like 53 degrees or something like
that you know like get out of your
gardener and they did did this like one
other time and then they just decided
it's it's it's not gonna be fun to pick
on this guy and that's what I kind of
figured was going on I just like oh okay
um don't give him a reaction don't give
him reaction and and then they they when
I found someone else to mess with but
the guys in the class later told me that
the group of three trainings that was
out there before our group came out like
they had one guy that they would just
harass and they would just make him
burst into tears every time in the end
quitting before I even started training
but you know you talk about this a lot
on the podcast how SEAL platoons are
just super aggressive and they're like
anybody looking for any weakness and if
you show a weakness it's gonna get
hammered
and then you're like no response no
response you got it you got to have
normal face your stifle your emotions or
your life is gonna be miserable until
you figure out how to deal with whatever
that weakness is the thing there's a
couple things that really bother me in
the world uh and I won't tell anyone
what they are no one knows not one
single person knows what really really
like there's a couple things if I if the
seal platoon would have known these
things I would have been eaten alive but
I never ever say and I won't tell anyone
right now
ever I'll put it in my will when I die
it'll be like hey you guys missed a huge
opportunity cuz you know and sometimes
you know it's things that can happen
with team guys just anyways just things
happen yeah and if you let it show
you're doomed you are or or they just
hammer that weakness until that nerve is
dead and it doesn't bother you anymore
sir don't get they'll work you through
it
uh-huh in a nice gentle way and did you
have any so you you you were crappy
runner obviously and you said that was a
gut check that's like me every run I
failed one run well after that run every
run I did I just ran as hard as I
possibly could sprint this is one of the
further until we were done yes I was
done would did anything else trip you up
at all on buds because everything all
the water stuff was easy pool comp
life-saving all that stuff was easy
because you did water yeah and nothing
about buds is easy but um it was all
stuff that I was really accustomed to
and so that so was like this is no big
deal this is no big deal that but it it
was friggin brutal like I wouldn't do it
I wouldn't want to do it again that's
for sure and then but the truth of it is
like as cool as I was in buds colder and
the team so stires I wasn't buds
tire during the team so yeah um great
guys it was a great experience I
finished up did you finish up with dive
phase I finished with land warfare so so
they switched it somewhere around when I
was there which was 1991 that's it was
just before we got there that we
switched it in fact I think there was
actually a class that did it the
opposite way did it the old way the way
you did it
before right that was still there when I
got there so right it was because of
Poole Khan was because it pulled so many
guys get kicked out during cool comp
that they're like why are we wait until
the end to do this let's shift it over
yeah Poole competency is something that
I knew zero about when I was coming into
the into buds and they had they had a
poster in the Med medical area and by
the grinder over there and it was a
Texas Chainsaw Massacre poster and and
yet they had written the Texas or the
buds pool caught mascar and I had like a
guy with a regulator getting ripped out
of his mouth and and who's the killer in
um in a leather face leather face was no
no like it had it like an AED TCL
instructor t-shirt on yeah and I just
remember walking by toes checking in or
whatever and I go I don't know what
that's all about and then I found out
that yeah they're gonna they're gonna
crush you in the water and what up then
you go to you into old school Airborne
School oh yeah for you so it was really
good but I was you know I was really
really cocky and when I go back and
examine my cockiness it was just here's
the deal I was super insecure and and
then compensate for it by being cocky
and hope hope sit no one figures out how
insecure I am but anyway the physical
aspect of jump school you know the runs
and stuff it's so easy and then but they
kind of get throttled back where it's
kind of a boot camp mentality you're not
used to it so me and the guys we were
going out drinking on and there's rules
you're not supposed to drink on a
weeknight and we were out drinking on a
weeknight or it was like a Sunday night
um the night before one of the last
before the final week of jump weeks and
I went up to get a pitcher a beer at the
the bar there and the guy who was the
bartender turns out he was a black hat
and so he's like hey or you'd jump
school and I'm like oh yeah yeah I'm in
jump school and he goes you're not
supposed to be drinking on weeknights
and then I I'm like yeah well whatever
and he goes do you know who I am and I
said no and he goes I'm a black cat and
he said it in a manner where it like
there should have been some spooky music
playing behind it and and I was like
okay well if you don't think I can you
know drink this beer and do the PT and
run in the morning and you're out of
your mind and he's like get out of my
bar rightly so kicked me out so we leave
the next morning we're on the bus on the
way to the drop zone for the first jump
and there's kind of a commotion outside
and I look and there's that guy that was
the bartender with his in and he's with
one of our guys cuz he was in a
different phase and so they pulled
everybody off the bus lined us up he
walked down he goes
oh here's the guy they pulled me out a
lineup pulled me behind one of the
buildings and Tunes me up you know I
kind of deserved I did didn't it kind of
I deserved it and so they let me have it
and then that was it I went back and did
three or four more jumps and then I was
getting ready to do my fifth jump which
is the last jump there at jump school
and the liaison officer came and pulled
me out and said hey you were drinking on
a weeknight I've got this statement
you're I'm pulling you out of this thing
and I'm gonna take you to njp which
non-judicial punishment campus so I was
like hey wait a minute these guys chewed
me out you know tuned me up a little bit
by that I mean I got punched me and I
had you know I had it coming it's all
good and you know they it was gonna be
done there and he goes nope we're not
having this this isn't it so you're
gonna go to Mass so I got pulled out of
the class the class graduated and left
and then this is like Friday you know
they did their last jump did the
graduation I was put in a holding
company and then I wanted to to
captain's mast in front of the Marine
Corps Lieutenant Colonel that was kind
of like the officer out there and
charged the Navy and Marines going
through jump school and you know I
called my dad
cuz he was still active duty at the time
he's a Jag she's shagging or yeah but he
couldn't pull any strings he's like hey
you're just gonna have to go in there
and own it so I go and I you know I sit
in the room coming in the guys office
they read me the rights they read the
statement against me in which which is
basically the story I just told you said
embellished a little bit more but it's
all good and so the the colonel he reads
his stuff and then he just looks up to
me at me and I'm standing at attention
and I'm I think okay I've done it again
I'm gonna get thrown out and he goes do
you do you have anything to say for
yourself and I said sir that's pretty
much what happened you know the
statement that he read out and I said
I've embarrassed the Navy and by in turn
the Marine Corps and all I can do is
take my lumps and press on with my
career and then he just stared at me and
he goes I find you a hundred bucks for
one month and I'll let you reclass up
with the next class and do your final
jump and get out of here and so you got
a hundred dollars extra a month jump pay
so it was really kind of a wash it was
awesome and then the the one guy that
had pulled me out of line and brought me
in there to mast he's like you know who
told you what to say but I found that
and I've always told young guys in
military career just own it if you get
in trouble own it it's when you make
excuses that you run into trouble but
when you're like this is what I did most
things that people have done guys have
come close to doing or did and just
didn't get in trouble for and when you
own it it just works out better in the
end to those every time no doubt about
that so now you go back to back to the
team where your team five check-in at
team five we didn't have sqt then so
what they did with us was we just kind
of bounced around so I worked in a
different department at the team that
worked in diving for a couple weeks
which worked in
for a couple weeks and I think I was at
the team for about four months and in
those days the team didn't deploy
we always had two platoons pushed
forward and the command was back so well
I think I was probably four or five
months that the team went out to Niland
worked at the old cap camp out there as
a camp guard it was great experience and
and then God in the my first platoon
which was an Arg alpha so we did the
whole deployment on a ship and that was
that was great had some awesome guys in
that platoon platoon chief was his guy
named bill Kuhn who's passed away now
and really miss him but he was just
super even-keel quiet direct you never
really saw him lose his temper and a
good good man good example for all of us
and then then a couple other guys I'll
get into here in a second you know and
then we wound up deploying on the ship
and we did a longer workup then it was
we did like almost a year-long workup
because we were going on the ark we had
to do everything guys were normally
doing like an eighth month or and then
they do a six-month stupi I yeah well
well when I did because I did two args
you know for those don't know it's
deploying on a ship when we did that it
would be we'd do the normal workup but
we do the normal workup before we
started our interoperability with the
Navy and the Marine Corps so that tacked
on that that technolon there work up the
Navy work up in the Marine Corps work up
so it was like we did two work ups kind
of and it was awesome training I got so
much out of out of that but then where
did you where'd you guys go into
ployment well we started our Westpac and
we were we just gotten into the
Philippines when the Sodom was saying
invaded Kuwait and all that stuff kicked
off so then we pushed over for Operation
Desert Shield and then was thought we
were going to go home we made it back to
the Philippines and then we stopped
there in the p.i for like three weeks
and then turned back around and went
back Oh
her for Operation Desert Storm did you
guys do anything we just did about so we
did the tanker boardings like to talk
about did a couple of those and then we
had a bunch of different operations that
we had slated on some of the islands off
the coast there that we would we got all
the way the point of doing rehearsals
for him and then like the Iraqis would
have just abandon the island or cut one
of the times when the helos flew over to
do a recon they surrender to the
helicopters and they just sent
helicopters in there and took all
through all Iraqis over but um Admiral
McRaven was our tasking a commander at
the time and so that was cool he was he
was really good to work for and then
like one of the guys in the platoon that
I'm that I told you I reached out to him
because I want to mention him because
he's kind of a bigger than life seal was
Steve Heinz and Steve is is he's a big
guy he's all you know at the time tatted
up quite a bit which in the early
nineties a lot not a lot of the guys had
tattoos he at some point in a bar fight
someone had cut him up with a knife so
he has these amazing scars Chris
crossing his chest he's really smart
he's got a razor-sharp whip wit and was
just a lot of fun to work with one of
those guys where is he as bad as things
ever got he's always cracking you know
cracking jokes so it's always funny
takes the edge off of it and one of the
things that he did really well was you
know when you're on a ship you're on the
ship and there are some guys that decide
they're gonna be condescending to
everybody and you know that just doesn't
get you far in life Steve Brant a PT for
the ship so we would do our own physical
training in the morning and then he had
one that he would run in the afternoon
and he would invite everybody to it and
the the captain of the ship came to his
PT the Master Chief for the ship was
there by the end of the deployment we
would have most of the flight deck would
be covered with guys coming to his PT
and then he'd be
cracking jokes the whole time everybody
loved him we would do like okay hey
we're gonna do a fantail shoot and we
would have different people from the
ship come up and we would let him shoot
our guns and be there Range Safety
officers so it's like hey all the guys
that work in the galley you know and the
galleys our mess hall come out we're
gonna run a shoot for you and then then
what happens they hook you up with food
you know you everybody chicken patties
more chicken patties you know maybe some
extra dessert and then everybody just
looked out for us and it was so good it
paid off in spades yeah that idea of
building relationships with people it's
just such a benefit across the board and
I certainly learned that literally
getting extra chicken patties and extra
chicken nuggets because I was bros with
the dude working in the front line a
handing out the chicken nuggets what
might sound like like that's whatever no
that's a real thing you're gonna cut in
Gator squares off the coast of Africa
for 90 days they don't have a lot of
food left and it gets down to okay what
are we gonna get or if you're out there
trying to get jacked by the way and if
you if you don't have fuel so yeah bro
out with those people a little bit
everybody why it's just like no skin off
your back not to ya
and you know I mean really that's what
karma is right
ya ain't good to people and and it comes
back to you yeah and so you guys did
some shit boardings and but then the
Gulf War and he was over in 72 hours
yeah was it done really quick and the
guys in the teams that did do missions
they they were generally liked by a
couple guys there's a couple platoons
that got so complicated that almost got
over and yeah it over coffee right that
was one platoon no was it I think it was
a team one platoon but it wasn't it
wasn't me I forget what it was but I was
right up their line and they punched
through was pretty crazy yeah yeah
that's like one of the and one of the
guys that was in a platoon I ended up in
a platoon with later but generally and
and even even doing ship boardings back
then was like ass
we did something real world real world
had a real world up everybody gather
round
yeah and that was the truth that was the
truth that was that was the way it was
hey if you did something real that was
awesome and and I mean when I was coming
in I had all these fantasies that once I
was in the SEAL Teams look there's
clandestine wars going on worldwide and
I'm gonna be all up in um I'm gonna be
fighting wars people don't even know
about and then I found out when I got to
the teams that there was no Wars in Guam
which was where my first deployment went
to yeah I felt like that same thing was
going on that there'd be like guys with
cool you'd get there and within a week
people Bellona
it load your stuff up we're going here
loading everything out and then it
doesn't happen that way or it does you
just got it you can't chase it I guess
well it happens more now I mean now
there's a lot more stuff going on and it
is going on and it is worldwide and you
see it in the news and sometimes you
don't but it is totally different it's
completely different now I mean we are
at war and so those little fantasies
that you have about going into countries
or though that that happens now whereas
in the 90s one happening no and and then
there are all these assumptions about
what you're gonna do when you're shot at
I remember like we shifted our immediate
action drills around at Nylund right
after the Panama thing happened on that
pettite airstrip and and we decided that
or it was decided by guys thinking about
they're like hey you're just when a when
the first gun shot goes you're just
gonna crawl so we did everything
crawling around in the desert and you
know it's not it's not how it goes
yeah no one knew no one knew and we
lacked simunition or yeah love laser
systems that we ended up using so it was
hard to know I mean even CQC was
especially totally ridiculous what we
used to do and you know new guys like me
they're telling me that this is what you
do and this is why you do it because
they have theory
behind it huh they have theories
theoretically and the theories are hard
to argue with a because you don't know
any better and be because they've kind
of pressure tested the theories in
little arguments amongst themselves so
hey you listen to him and you think okay
this is the way it is and then you find
out well then everyone found out
actually even just when they started
implementing paintball and simunition it
was like you know what this doesn't seem
like a smart idea it doesn't seem like a
smart idea for all of us to be standing
in the hallway that that's the that's
one of the big ones it's so obvious you
know my first Platoon it was like hey
everyone stand up all way and you get
ready to go in the next room and that's
cool then second Platoon same way it was
until either like I think it was even
past I think it was I think it was in no
I'm trying to think of the year but like
98 is when I started seeing a change in
hey this is not smart because watch what
happens you guys are all line up in the
hallway cool somebody sticks a
simunition gun around the corner of the
hallway and mows down eight people right
and the first reaction is like well that
wouldn't happen it just happened
it just happened well that guy wasn't
aiming yeah you don't need to aim you
have an automatic weapon and so that was
kind of the beginning or that definitely
had an impact on the way stuff is gonna
be and it's just like you said like you
talked about in Panama those guys and
how the guys made theoretical changes
which is hey when the shooting starts
you're gonna crawl well in the desert
your contact is likely to be much
further away and you have much greater
distance to travel in order to break
contact or do assault so if if what
you're doing is calling not saying
there's no times where you will be
sucking mud because you certainly can be
but there's a difference between
effective fire and an effective fire and
there's this difference between dead
space and when you're in in open space
where you can actually get hit so yeah
it's weird it was awesome and weird to
see all that unfold and it is actually
very similar to what the UFC did to
martial arts you know sure yeah because
everything was theoretical and again it
was you remember some of the kind of
your martial arts that they'd fellow out
us and the teams and I remember one in
particular where it was hey when you hit
the guy here his I forget what they
called it they had a scientific name for
it his automatic reaction but they had
some scientific sound where his
automatic reaction his physiological
reaction is going to be to do this and
then when they do that you can do this
and then went and when you do this it's
gonna call me that and they had these
big scenarios that would they would play
out and that was what it was hey when
you get it like it was literally when
you hit the guy in the neck it's gonna
cause him to like fold to one side and
and and everyone that gets hit in the
neck arches their back and sticks their
chin out then you'll hit him with this
it was there's there that that's what
they're saying and then you can't say
well hey man go ahead and like hit me in
the neck with all your might and I
actually did do that I actually did say
like hit me see if that happens and it
didn't happen and then I got some other
weird psychobabble circular argument
about well that's because you're
expecting it well okay but do it when
I'm not expect you know it just it's
just one of these things strike the neck
stomp the groin rake the eyes restart
the drawing was it the skies it's like a
soft combat assault system or something
like that it was and we got we went
through a whole bunch of those and all
it takes is a couple people in a
leadership position to get convinced by
this if I notice IRA saw a lot of
circular arguments and those things and
it's so that that thing so when the UFC
started it was like oh these kungfu guys
or whatever these karate guys or
whatever these ninjutsu guys or whatever
whatever their martial art was and they
had the thing that oh when I throw punch
you your breathing will be incapacitated
for approximately 45 seconds it's
generally about 45 seconds when you hit
someone to throat in order for the nuke
let's about a 45 seconds you get about a
45 second window where now you want
attack the nerve basis you want to
attack the solar plexus when you get him
the solar plexus prosody
now you got about another 45 seconds
this is we could rape the eyes I knew it
some Grandmaster can stick that that was
it and and so when the UFC came around
it was like oh all of a sudden that
doesn't work and it's the same thing
that happened pre and I'll even say pre
simunition pre paintball and pre and we
use miles gear but miles gear was kind
of weak yeah miles get wasn't quite good
enough which is for those you don't know
it's like a laser tag system that you
mounted on your wheel weapons but it it
wasn't very accurate you had to deal
with jams and your blanks it was just it
wasn't that good you know but those
things definitely started to make it
lean towards oh that's just this theory
doesn't seem to hold the water that we
all thought that it held yeah yeah but
you know what here's the thing even if
we were crawling as long as we had a
plan and rehearsed it that was way
better than stuff that wasn't so a lot
of those guys that did that first those
first fighting systems that there was a
lot of goofy stuff when they would get
in a street fight they would just still
do okay because what what's I think
Patton said that thing about it and a
good plan now is better than a perfect
plan later right you know that's a good
point now that I think about if you
think about the tactics so you got told
after Panama to crawl and that seems
kind of crazy right now and then eh
if you think about it as abroad hey what
we're gonna do is crawl whole time think
about this though remember when it was a
whole squad getting up online and moving
get them but getting up and running all
at one time
yeah just as ridiculous just yeah just
dicking exactly and there's a time and
place for bullying there's a time and
place for both things and you know as
memory I was at I was at one of the
teams I don't know a six months ago a
year ago we were talking tactics and a
guy asked me like hey where does the
argument haven't been your team the the
question was like where does the
commander go in this situation and it
wasn't one group was saying they
shouldn't be in the rear and the other
group saying no before I was my team
okay yeah
and I was like listen there's different
times where the commander needs to be in
a different spot and where the commander
should be is where he isn't in the weeds
but still kind of understands what's
happening and can provide them as
command and control something the answer
is not he should be here the answer is
where should he be for that particular
situation and does the commander have
the understanding the tactical
understanding and the operational
understanding to go oh you know what if
these guys are busting into a building
right here and I go into that building
and there's contact I'm gonna be sucked
into that contact and I'm not gonna be
able to control anything
contrary to that if I'm way at the back
where the contact happens and I don't
even know what building it's in that's a
problem too where should I be I should
be where I can provide the best command
and control and that's very adaptable
it's very easy to adapt but it's very
also very easy for people to come up
with doctrine and then supporting
arguments supporting the theories that
that are very hard to argue against
could you get into circular arguments
against crazy people yeah emotionally
attached to whatever the answer oh
that's a stinger and the this is why I
think NSW has always been so successful
and I think will continue to be
successful is because we're not so rigid
in what we do and it's so it's in one
ways it's a weakness but it's also at
the same time our greatest strength
because everything I've done on
deployment most things actually was not
exactly something that I trained for but
the training that I got was 30% there to
where it was easy to pivot boom and into
whatever whatever is being requested
overseas yeah and the training that you
got trained you to think not just hey
this is what you're gonna do 100% of the
time it's a hey this is gonna work in
this situation but you should be looking
around you should have your head on a
swivel you should be looking for work
you know all those little little like
mantras that you get told
they actually make sense because it's
not just do this same thing every time
it's read and react right I didn't react
that's one of the first things you
started here
like read and react because you don't
just do you actually read and you
actually assess so those are all
important anything else from that first
deployment besides just being on the are
can be you know unmanned hot long ten
month deployment I remember it by the
end of the deployment after that
deployment none of us wanted to talk to
each other for a while it was like you'd
see guys around the Krannert hey and
then because it was just so long and
there's no internet there's no internet
you know you communication with home is
snail mail letters to us three-week
conversations you have back and forth
and and the whole platoon is in a room
that's twice the size of this the whole
racks are stacked for high you you've
got like eighty movies on videotape and
they're just running constantly and
you've seen every one of these eighty
movies a 500 times because they're
literally playing non-stop in the
platoon space region dick ulis we got on
a kick and this is the another arc
deployment I went on later when I've
gone to Somalia but we got on a kick
with what's the movie where the girls
had spins around the exorcist Exorcist
so we're watching The Exorcist over and
over and over again
and right about that was the time we did
the the Shellback ceremony where
overlook later and so there was only two
guys in the platoon that had done it so
all the rest of us were logs and we're
going through it and basically all they
do is throw food it's you and spray you
with water which okay is like buds we
were just doing it and guys have come by
with like all these logs over here and I
remember one of the guys gone the power
of Christ compels you
power of Christ compels you and then we
all started shouting it and the guy just
looked at us for a second and wandered
off and someone else came behind with
the hose and spray us a little bit but
they had no idea what to make of us at
all
awesome you come home from that
deployment and then what then what's up
what's next then I went and worked in
the armory for a little bit and waited
to pick up another another platoon then
after that I did I worked in the armory
for another six months
did another platoon and then that was a
special you went you went to the armory
because you were interest I was a gunner
Jay and so I was ordnance rep what what
position were you and your first platoon
oh good point
so I was a sniper but they didn't we
didn't have any stubble you didn't have
a sniper course so there was a guy that
had just come from reappointment point
man in second squad and the first squad
point man was a sniper and he'd been to
the army Sniper school yeah so they ran
ran me through some different training
and stuff like that to get me like kind
of qualified but I didn't have a
certificate or nothing and and it was
really minor stuff so me and the other
sniper would you know practice just
calling stuff out and then when we do
the tanker boardings I'd be up in the
helo eyes above pass an info and so when
I got back I went to I was working in
ordnance and then I got an opportunity
to go to the second nsw sniper course
they ran on the west coast and that was
that was brutal I've never failed
anything up until then I'd never failed
anything in my life and I didn't make it
through the first night of course I
passed the shooting portion which most
guys pass but and that's like five weeks
straight of shooting but then when it
came to stalking I just didn't get it
and I lacked the patience that I needed
that I later figured it out and so I
didn't past I came out of there without
not a sniper call but in advance
marksman qual um the badge of dishonor
yeah pretty much
and guys so actually it's funny because
I say that jokingly but like everybody
knows that how hard that's they used to
fail everyone in stock and it was crazy
my my course there's only two guys that
graduated with a call with a sniper qual
out of like how much how much of that
was the seal instructor bro team guys
going we're gonna have the hardest
course ever no one's gonna make it
through it's gonna be the toughest
course I'd write on yeah yeah I mean I
mean I would have been in that position
I think there was there was definitely a
piece of that because there was like
some guys getting pretty dang excited
and screaming and yell at you every yard
line you're like good grief what's going
on and um but I don't know if that would
have made a difference for me passing or
not like had it been more leveled out
and they hadn't gotten too excited about
it yeah which I'm not saying they did
but that's just that's how it rolled out
so ii and i i play too
and i was a again a point man and then I
think I acted as a sniper but then the
sniper thing kind of fell off the radar
for NSW a little bit it wasn't a
priority for anybody and did a second
platoon which is a spec alpha-2 and went
to the Philippines or no we went to Guam
that's where we met yeah at the jungle
and Guam Minh and the jungle was this
bar yeah the German air was not a jungle
the jungle was the bar that everybody
went to and then yeah did a platoon then
I wound up doing a year overseas well I
went home for a week and then came back
with another platoon straight away and
did did that and those were great
experiences I mean who travelled around
a lot we did a lot of water work back in
the day a lot of tanker boarding a lot
of diving all that didn't do anything
real and then when I came back from
those deployments I went to work in our
training cell at the team
and the guy was working in the land
warfare section working for a guy named
Danny Carroll who at the time was uh I
don't have to back up a little bit on
this but he he was just he was awesome
to work for he's he's one of these guys
that no matter how bad anything ever was
he never complained he might complain to
someone that was his peer but he never
complained down and then never
complained about oh this is stupid or he
was not the torturer genius which when
things were hard and he wasn't
complaining then it wasn't hard and he
he's another guy with a really good
sense of humor and uh and just a good
good time to be around but the biggest
thing about him was just like never ever
complain always something positive to
say and and was was an expert and then
when he did give you a critique he
didn't it wasn't condescending so he was
somebody I looked up to and he wasn't in
my platoon he's actually a leadership
and my sister platoon and I would go
over and talk to him all the time and
like back in the day I had my hair
bleached white it was always long you
know I was never in the right uniform
ever because not being a uniform made me
feel special because I was insecure and
all all people would just scream at me
cut your hair get in uniform but they
never would tell you you know hey do it
then one day Danny goes hey Jason why
don't you why don't you cut your hair
it's so easy to have a decent haircut
and be in the right uniform and your
life is gonna be so much better and you
should just try it for a little bit and
he just laid it out and it there was no
condescension behind it was just
straight-up advice from one friend to
another and um and so I tried it now I
was like hey this is amazing like people
aren't asking like hey what are you
doing tonight people are actually giving
me stuff to do and then leaving me alone
and let me do it because they trusted me
that I was going to be proof you know be
professional about it and after
and working for him I got the
opportunity because when the teams ran
sniper courses I gotta interject real
quick because there's also those guys
that would be like they're condescending
and and all you do is you know the you
know the guy that's all straight-laced
running around the team looking like a
dork and you just think when you're a
young team guy you're like this guy's a
dork he doesn't he doesn't and if they
come up and say something you're just
mad at him you know you're just like
you're stupid you don't get it
you don't know what it's like to be
young jock right and that's how
everybody else was it was for me because
they're like really yeah but you know
Danny was a beast and yeah and so was
like yeah I'm gonna listen to what he's
saying you know there's an important two
things about Steve Lyons and and Danny
which I didn't work with either of those
guys other than periphery look
peripherally through through the years
no I think Steve Hines put was that
freefall school with me and it was an
island forever so whatever and Danny
Carroll well I didn't I remember Danny
from being on deployment and hit my LPO
was good friends with him and so you
know we were always linked up and but
what I was gonna say is you you mention
this real quick
he was good operator like he was Oh guys
that because if you were good at your
job yeah that's like the base level of
having respect and getting people listen
to you is oh this guy is really good at
his job and you'd even hear before we
before the word operator had the had the
kind of meaning that it has today where
it's like oh he's an operator and it
kind of has this taken on a life of its
own but back then and be like oh yeah
that guy is a good operator and it
really meant something when I would hear
that about someone yeah like hey that
guy's a really good operator and you
think oh wow that guy's that means he
can shoot well that means you can
navigate well that means he can dive
well that means he's he keeps his cool
it like men to all those things that
guy's a good operator and so that sort
of Nemea was the baseline and especially
for guys that I looked up to at my team
when I was a new guy it was the guys
where you'd hear all that geyser
good operator and then it was okay and
it wasn't like that was everyone they
owned it on a big number of people yeah
and and to develop a reputation as a
good operator when there's no war going
on it's actually very hard to do that
because what that means is every one of
these stupid training missions every one
of these dumb dives that everyone's
bitching about you're actually taking
completely serious and you're doing your
best and you're teaching other people
and that is what
that's what developed the reputation
back then was like this guy's a good
operator yeah yeah definitely and so
then then that guy's I got the kind of
wasta where he can hand out advice and
then the fact that he gives it out
without being condescending or straight
up it's just so much it's worth
absorbing what about did you so what are
the schools you go to did you get any
what about did you go to sere school
yeah good time you know that was a it
was a I forget when it I think it was in
this period after I did those two
platoons I finally got sucked into going
to sere school and I remember I didn't
get waterboarded for some reason in sere
school but I did kill and eat a
rattlesnake and they're like hey you're
not supposed to do that and then I got
caught and then I'm like okay well but
this is just in the field training
portion where you know you're doing
patrolling and danger crossings that's
all you're doing all day and then you
have these little land nav exercise that
you're doing which were super easy for
me because this is what we did so I
would just just get them done and be
done sleeping and hungry and trying to
eat grasshoppers and everything cuz they
don't feed you for the whole week and
then when they catch you and they put
you into that that prison camp so the
first thing they do is I have everybody
line up and then they strip you down
naked because apparently they're they're
checking you for ticks so then they see
all my tattoos and one of the
instructors is like hey this guy's got
the mark of the devil because the guys
all have that Russian accent right yeah
so I get I get grabbed and then I'm in
the circle of these instructor
and they're like he's got the mark of
the devil and they're kind of shoving me
back and forth and I'm like okay this is
kind of fun this is you know this isn't
a big deal and then a guy that's
straight across from me I can remember
seeing a big black hand come over his
shoulder and it like covers up half of
his chest like like Andre the Giant big
and just move the dude away and then
another guy a hand moves the other guy
way and then there's this just mountain
of a man grabbed me with his left hand
picks me up they're only allowed to like
hit you from out here to here but it was
like you know those those images in
Rocky where I was like stars and that's
just oh that was that little smirk I
just had on my face laying on the ground
over there and oh here comes again boom
and humbling I literally got the exact
same treatment I remember I was in some
vehicle and it was after you got you
avoided capture and then eventually they
just call up in the woods and I go come
down you have to surrender now yeah so
we had avoided capture me and my pilot
buddy
we had avoided capture we go down and
get in the vehicle they drive us
somewhere and I'm just you know
everything's a joke whatever and get out
of the vehicle and you know some guys
yelling at us with the fake Russian
accent and I'm just laughing at it
inside and which means you know I'm like
kind of probably got that I was 19 yeah
and the dude the dude comes over and he
like yells at me and I you know who
knows what I said to prove that I was a
tough guy and this dude I was like I
can't believe he just did that uh and
okay well good times so that must be
they must they must know who we are
coming in they must look at the young
punks and go yep I got this guy hey I
got what number is Gartner yeah I mean
over here from SEAL Team 5
what number is willing coming over here
from SEAL team one I'm gonna get me some
of that
yeah and it's gotta go I'm just an
immense amount of satisfaction when that
look it's knocked off your face cuz they
can just see the light come out of your
eyes and you're like oh it's a I mean
I've been punched many times yeah
that open hand smack full-on and I don't
know what you're talking about only
bringing it back to wherever this
brother brought it back all the way got
it all the way home dude it was a good
one and I've been like I said I've been
hit before I've been knocked out before
it didn't knock me out but I was it was
definitely uh it was definitely reality
oh oh yeah these guys are these guys are
not playing around these guys are gonna
take pleasure and beating the crap out
of me and they're gonna do it if they if
I give them any reason to so in which
event so that was two deployments you
come back you're in training how much
did you learn when you were working in
training because I know I as an e5
working in SEAL team one training cell
learned like just mountains of
information tons yeah exactly because
that's when when you have to teach
something as one you got to really
absorb it because you have to completely
understand it and everything else so
that's when it opened up the curtain for
me so I saw everything that went into
training that was behind the scenes you
know when you go through the training
like oh okay well there's a lot that
goes on from laying on the ranges to
doing the med drills to order in the
ammo to trying to make the training
relevant and realistic for the guy so it
you just don't feel like you're wasting
their time but yeah and then it was at
that at that time that I went back and
restocked and got my sniper qual and
then was an instructor for a couple of
different sniper courses that period the
difference is what you was there
something you said you didn't get it the
stock from the first time around was it
like you didn't quite figure out
deadspace was that you just didn't have
the patience for it were you like
whatever what what what did you what
changed about you what did you learn it
by oh so I so they drop you off and then
they'll just point Hey the observation
point is that way and during
stalk your you're trying to find where
these other guys are at and and you
don't know and their other their sniper
instructors so they have really really
good skills and optics and they're
sitting out somewhere shouldn't not
totally concealed but you've got you've
got to find them before you move and the
mistake I was making before is that
getting impatient and I'm just like I'll
just start going that way and along the
way I'll figure out where they're at and
as opposed to okay I'm going to just sit
right here and take my time and figure
out where everything is and how
everything's laid out and then try and
find the opie before I move down toward
it at all no you'd have to I'd have to
move laterally one way or the other to
figure it out and so typically on the
stalks when it clicked for me I would be
the last guy to leak to actually leave
where they drop us off and I'd be the
first guy done and typically I'd spend
almost no time crawling because I would
do do the this you know find the opie
once I had it located then I would study
their terrain really hard and figure out
where I need to go to get within that
200 yards to do your you know final shot
do you figure this out on your own well
they tell you that but I just started
listening to one and and and it clicked
they're like hey you gotta find the LP
okay cuz yeah isn't it strange and I
mean well your kids well you got kids
are old enough like it's the same thing
with your kids you you tell them like
hey figure out where the Opie is before
you start crawling or whatever it is
less life lesson that you learned hit in
the head with a baseball bat and you try
and give your kids a hint or just tell
them and they're just like no I'm just
going to start moving yeah I got this
yeah and I have no idea how to deal with
that
it's it's funny because I think you and
I have had a lot of the same experiences
with with dealing with our kids you know
like hey I'm telling you I've lived
through this here's what you should do
and but now I've come to the point where
I'm still gonna tell him but I know what
they're probably gonna do and then yeah
and then just wait and see
keep your hungers cross yeah yes is what
people say okay so when I noticed one of
the things that I'm actually thinking
about this right now when I was in
training cell and I was so because I was
single and didn't care about anything
else and so I taught everything it was
like oh well there's land warfare trip
cold Cochise land warfare
oh there's CQC trip go teach that go
teach combats for Marty just teach
everything because because in and now I
look back how awesome it must be when
you got like guys like that at the team
who were just like oh yeah I don't mind
going down another month-long trip back
to back doesn't matter we'll go train
and it wasn't just me that wasn't it's
like all my all my bros that you know I
was friends with all my guys from team
when we're all saying that like hey
we'll go teach whatever you said was on
the road we don't care it's awesome I
had a Volkswagen van that I've taken all
the seats out of the back and just line
of carpet and I had some some bean bags
in there and when I was on the stand I
slept in the parking lot for like I
think eight months because I was like I
would rather be on a trip collect
collecting per diem and doing stuff than
sitting here and so that's that's where
that's where I was it was always out on
training block I was running an sqt I
wasn't running it but I was one of the
instructors on an ST T when we used to
run s TT at the team so it was a bunch
of new guys we were putting him through
training and I remember right now I'm
remembering this
there was like multiple officers in the
same s TT class so each squad had
multiple officers so we were rotating
through like okay it's your turn Reese
quad leader it's your turn during I ads
and now that I think about it I remember
so much of looking at like oh you'd see
one guy do it and he'd be all screwed up
and you'd say what is wrong with this
guy oh he's shooting the whole time
instead of looking around and then just
from one iteration and the big
difference is when you're not doing the
I ad when you're actually watching it
unfold everything becomes so good with
this is like
talk about detaching your this is my
earliest or some of my earlier
experiences being detached asleep you're
watching these immediate action drills
unfold and I remember one officer that
was all jacked up and I watched him like
why is why can't this squad do a
whatever why can't this squad do a
strong left or whatever or appeal right
why they do it what is wrong so I'm
watching this one officer and the other
officer like oh this officer did it fine
I watched him the contact happens and
that people start shooting and then the
guy looks around and makes a call i
watch this other officer the contact
happens he starts shooting and he
doesn't stop shooting and no one's
making the call and it was just as
simple as like hey man your job is not
to shoot your job is to make you know
look around and make a call that you
learned so much when you're instructing
not only because you have to think about
what you say and you have to be able to
articulate why and that makes you dig
deep into the reason why and then you
get to detach and actually watch it
unfold and watch these little minor
mistakes happen and then you get to
correct them and then you get to
recognize them in yourself when you make
them it's a powerful thing to and I when
I was at trade it I think we did a good
job of transfer because no one you know
used to be only one who the trainee I
don't want to go to training I don't go
to trade that I think we did a good job
of transferring the mentality to hey if
you want to get good at this job you got
to come here you got to yeah which I
believe it's the truth
so anyone if you want to get good at
something
just try and teach it same thing with
jiu-jitsu as well the um that was an SOP
for us when when I was in land warfare
at five was when a guy was having a hard
time we pull him up as like hey come
stand next to me they are so and just
watch your guys eighty percent of the
time that would that would all fix the
problem yeah yeah which is a testament
to just attachment yeah it is is a
testament to detachment in man once you
learn how to detach
even though you're in the situation it's
like just makes life so much easier so
much easier okay so now what you'd do
another patoot so just I got three
platoons on my belt and working in in
land warfare or at trade at you know
training sell at the team and then one
of the the platoons that was on the Arg
they were gonna pull into Somalia and
help the MER the UN pulled out of Somali
this is ninety five and one of their
their sniper in their platoon got thrown
in jail in Hong Kong and was a big
international incident so they were down
a sniper
so I happen to be on quarterdeck watch
when the OIC the platoon called back to
the team and said we need another sniper
out here we're down one and we know
we're gonna go into Somalia here in like
three months and I'm like hey I'm a
sniper and I'm a sniper instructor send
me so I passed it back to the XO and
there are actually a couple there was
another guy that was senior to me as an
e6 at the time that was gonna go and
then something came up at the last
second he couldn't go so they're like
hey you're going so I packed up my stuff
they flew me over to Bahrain I'm the
when the ship pulled in I met up with
the platoon and then got in the platoon
and about six weeks later we went up in
Somalia so like I just got lucky
you know because you can't you can't
chase it and then in the 90s there was
no like at that point I think there had
been two other platoons that had cycled
through Somalia and and both of them had
had gotten in troops in contact which
was a dream for all of us yeah and
timing-wise
this is like two years after the Big
Black Hawk Down thing happened there so
gotten a platoon another aquatune back
on the same ship that I did my first our
game we
in the same burning space what ship was
it the the Ogden LBD 5 yeah it's um and
but another guy that was really another
guy that was a big mentor of mine I
looked up to a lot was uh and he was the
LPO as Monty tree sighs and money had
been around SW for a long time and he
had the additional deal where he'd he
had broken service so he was a police
officer up in Los Angeles and he had a
lot of you know because those guys he'd
actually been in gunfights before and in
high-stress situations so it was it was
really good having him having him there
and then when we did go ashore myself
and the other night we split up into two
different sniper elements and money was
with my element and then the Eldar
sniper was with the the chief was with
him and then they each of it's bad like
five guys in our group because it was an
excuse to get ashore and the reason and
this was completely the Marines deal
they were there to pull the UN out but
they didn't have the 50 caliber sniper
rifle capability and that's something
that they wanted to have so that they
could reach out these long distance and
be a little bit more surgical with their
application of force smarter so we were
our officers were able to sell it and
and then we got to go ashore doing that
and that was uh how many how many days
did you spend on the ground man we were
only in there for like three days
and so the Marines I think we were on
the the second lift ashore and I was
down on the airfield but the airfield in
Mogadishu reports right up against the
ocean and and it's the reason I say
mm-hmm is because before this or maybe
it was after this but I was cutting
Gator squares which means driving around
in circles off the coast of Somalia for
for a long time and we were supposed to
go in and we were we
we got our issue of ammo real ammo you
know all of our key AR mor mags were
loaded our I remember I put the real 40
mike-mike into my vest for the first
time and they didn't quite fit right
like it was a yeah no one's longer yeah
no one had ever you know done it or no
like I didn't know and and so here we
were and we and so we did all kinds of
maps we were ready to go in and then we
never went in which was and part of the
reason we didn't go in is the same
reason we didn't go into Rwanda because
Black Hawk Down had happened they were
just like mmm they were everyone was
super hyper cautious about everything
and so yeah I remember we were going it
we were actually taking boats into the
airfield that's what we were gonna do so
I remember that of your field in Lewis
then so ah this is a funny you guys
flying in helicopters in no II wrote in
an on one of the big hovercraft the elk
act but we went in so okay this is not
dangerous now but you know nobody share
ports controlled by the UN and then
there's that green Beach right there
which is infested with bull sharks I
think there are like 12 total shark
attacks and a couple fatalities on that
beach so we got tasked with doing the
hydrographic reconnaissance there's some
story about some kind of slaughterhouse
or something that like I never saw it
but that was the story the owner there's
a camel slaughterhouse that's just
teeming with blood and the sharks can't
resist that's exactly what we are going
in with we had that story that yeah
story like the midget sniper in Iraq and
they're all they're all just waiting for
you to hit the water yeah um you know
which is kind of what I think anytime
I'm doing anything at night in in the
ocean you're like like the Sharks are
just waiting right there for you to come
in and just come up and bite you I'm so
stupid
I never think about that I never one
time in my whole career thought okay I'm
getting in the water tonight it's
Southern California there's big sharks
that live here there could be one I
never thought about that for whatever
reason I don't know
I do I do but then I'm like I'm cold now
I think about something else
so you're you guys take accent so wait
so we go to do a Hydra recon and because
of the sharks we got to do this big
perpendicular Hydra recon perpendicular
parallel whatever um and we're doing it
with zodiacs and then we're spaced every
50 yards and then the ribs on the
outside of it and the water is I mean so
here's not swimming we're not you taking
yourself from boats and um there was a
big net that we had to get out of there
so that the elk acts and when craft come
in so I'm in the first rib and then and
a rib is uh like an inflatable hole 30
feet and then the next one out is like
50 yards past mine so the water super
clear like you can see the bottom it's
like 60 feet deep and the boat out past
me they're all yelling they're like hey
look down there's some sharks down there
so one of the the team guy that was in
that boat jumps up on the the sponson of
the rib to look at the sharks and slips
in the water and it was like he hit a
trampoline I don't know how he did it
because that the ribs are so high out of
the water you're like how do you even
get it but he got in and he was out so
fast I'm not even sure he got wet and I
don't blame him but no we went in there
was just a the planning cycle was crazy
for that for days everybody was down to
the spot they were gonna be in we didn't
our study there was a bunker that we
wanted to use that would be a good
position from where we were at so we run
like the third lift on the elk ax and
elk ax those big hovercraft but you
can't sit out on the deck so they had
this big 40-foot mil van strapped to the
deck you went inside of it and then
there was a bunch of troop seating and
then we just rode in on that hope the
thing didn't sink because you would just
be done
got out and then patrolled over to our
spot where we wanted to set up in this
dis bunker and it didn't work the slits
out of the bunker the the scope of my 50
Cal would stick out and the scope was
looking right at the cement so then we
built we got up on top of the bunker and
we started filling sandbags moving
sandbags around made ourselves a little
like firing position on top of that
bunker and and that's really snow
covering down on your covering down
looking for attackers on they came in to
try and attack the airfield
so the airfield was controlled so we had
set a perimeter up inside of the UN
perimeter that was already there and so
the first day there nothing really
happened because it was all status quo
the UN controlled the airfield their
watchtowers and stuff like that and then
we had a line set up that was just a
narrow strip of beach between us in the
ocean so when the UN left and we would
just all fall back into the amphibs and
go back out to the to the ships so the
first day you know there's all his
tracer fire going on Mogadishu is pretty
active not much happened then the next
morning at like 4:00 a.m. all the manned
positions were replaced by tanks and
then everybody left and they just there
was a big camp like five hundred yards
to the south of us and they just they
just a bit they just left everything
there and then then at like 8:00 in the
morning the tanks all left and just left
it open so there was this weird period
of time where everyone was like what
just happened and then a lot of the
civilian populace started piling in
because there was like there's water
there's building materials they were
ripping the roofing off a lot of the
buildings that these guys had just
abandoned and then about an hour after
that the you know you had your different
war loads and factions figured out what
was going on
and then they had to stop people from
getting stuff because they wanted it so
we watch like a big crowd of people and
I was just like in that movie there's a
big crowd of people ripping stuff
running everywhere ripping stuff out of
these buildings and then guys show up
with a jeep with like a PKM which is a
belt-fed machine gun on the back and
just aim at the people and start
shooting them and then you just see it
like oil on water or whatever everyone
moved and they're just all taking off so
one clan kind of took control of a camp
that was at five hundred yards to the
south under the runway there five six
hundred yards away from us was the edge
of that camp that was you and controlled
the other clan which these two major
factions of warlords down there
controlled the other under the runway at
one point they moved down the runway and
tried to attack this other clan that was
holding because you can't control half
of a runway and they had like this crate
they had crazy technicals and our rules
engaging would say they can have
technicals out and that's a civilian
vehicle it's like a road warrior vehicle
with some kind of crude crew-served
weapon in the back and they had one was
like a big five ton truck with a quad
anti-aircraft gun sit in the back with a
guy like you know dialing a thing to
move it around and stuff and they
weren't halfway down the runway they
tried to shoot it out but the this other
camp the other factions shot back and
shot him off of there so that went on
but that was really those two fad there
was some spillover toward us what was
his two factions shooting at each other
well at some point people stood they
started the one faction that controlled
the south this camp to the south under
the runway started to shoot at us and so
we started taking a lot of
indiscriminate small arms fire and then
we had a recoilless rifle launched at us
but it went over and landed in the ocean
and some random RPGs it was all pretty
far away so you know as you know in an
urban environment it's it's really
difficult to tell
getting shot at and then especially when
there are six hundred yards away there's
it's daylight you can't see any muzzle
flash so unless somebody gets really
sloppy or you're really lucky you're not
gonna see it and the way Mogadishu is
like a big hillside with all these
buildings and rolls up it's just not
like you're looking at one set of
buildings you're looking at like a roll
buildings then behind you - another roll
buildings infinite
yeah just Agility's giant mouse maze so
um saw a guy on a roof with an RPG and
then a second later one gets launched at
us and then we're like oh okay buddy
missed and then so basically at that
point they're like you're you're cleared
hot this is silly we've met our rules of
engagement cuz and then back in the 90s
the appetite for applying lethal force
was was pretty subdued it's not as
liberal as it is today and how it should
be and so it took us a little while to
get there and I'm like okay these guys
are bad these guys are obviously trying
to get us so you're cleared hot find
somebody to shoot in can find anyone to
shoot for a while then this camp that
was 500 yards the south of us we saw a
group of like seven guys two of them had
RPGs a rocket-propelled grenades and
other guys patrolling with like two
peak-to-peak a.m. Gunners there belt-fed
machine guns and like an a gunner and
they're patrolling we can see him we can
see him and now they come out the front
of the camp and at the gate of that camp
which is facing us 500 yards away
there's two sandbagged positions for the
watches who would be up there to check
people coming in and out and a guy there
was one guy he had a gray ironically he
had a grey t-shirt on that said army
right and he's got an RPG and he's
definitely in charge and he put a pee
cam on one of the sandbags point nose
was talking to guys given direction
turns around puts the the RPG on his
shoulder and it's looking at us through
the sight and so ROIC
is like okay well hey let's hold on see
we're doing the money whose money's
really savvy he's like hey they're
getting ready to shoot at us he's
adjusting the sights right now he's
getting and we wanted to preempt this so
I could shoot it the guy before he got a
chance to launch the RPG cuz it's closed
that's a good plan so all I see is like
okay go shoot him so I've got kind of it
I've got a really jacked up firing
position it's a 500 yard shot I I
squeeze squeeze around off boom and then
apparently I missed so which which I
with my shooting position was not good
and I was really really like excited
either what they call you know buck
fever what's the first time I've ever
shot at a human so I was worked up
pretty good and then the guy who was
spotting for me who wasn't a spotter
because that was the sniper was in the
other platoon or at the other of the
other firing position he was sitting
right next to me on the sandbags looking
through the spotting scope and when the
50 Cal went off it's got a big muzzle
break so the recoil doesn't break a
collarbone it ports back it just blew a
bunch of sand in his eyes and knocked
the spotting scope right out of his
hands
so Monty's like hey you missed I'm like
do you have a correction and and he's
like no and it sounded like he was
talking in slow motion cuz he was just
just super calm and cool and I'm like oh
no now I'm questioning whether I might
might my dope my dad on previous
GameInformer yards is any good or
anything that 50 Cal you to take the
entire bolt out of the gun knock the
brass out from the round you just fired
put a new round in chamber it and reload
so I came heard it reload downrange
they were they were like ooh they just
shot at us you know so the guy was like
wow
so they're starting to talk and now he's
got that RPG on his shoulder and I hold
a little harder I take a breath let half
out start to squeeze that trigger I get
that surprise bang boom pull the bolt
out knocking the brass out load another
round and I'm going did I hit and our
comms guy had grabbed by nose and he
goes oh man and I'm like did I hit and
he goes God darn it good grief and I'm
thinking that he's gonna tell me that I
missed by like half a mile and he
doesn't even know what kind of
correction to give me and I hit him in
the arm I'm like dude what happened who
did I hit any good and he didn't even
hear me he goes he is oh that had to
hurt
so now that PKM gunner who who was set
up on the sandbags he just lets her rip
and so there's the the the bull whit
craps of those rounds going over the top
of us and money's like hey I think this
guy's like right at 500 yards you got
your dialed in you know he's just
talking in my ear like man like we're
going to get the mail or something or or
whatever just calm and then so I can't
see the guy at all all I can see is the
muzzle flash so I put the crosshairs in
the middle of the muzzle flash squeeze
the round off reload come back up and
look to see what what had happened
and there was a the gun had spilled over
the front side of the sandbags there was
a huge divot in the sandbags I couldn't
see you know I couldn't tell I think I
hit the rifle but then he had spilled
out he was out from the side of the
sandbags on his side and and it's just
his guts were everywhere he was flailing
around for a little bit and then he
expired I assumed because I quit looking
at him at that point because a Jeep had
now shown up and it had like one of
their 50 51 cows in the back and the
guys just do
and I'm thinking oh man we've grabbed a
tiger by the tail because I've got this
round I can you know one round at a time
and I'm waiting for like there was a tow
missile gunner right near our position
for him to light it up but we've gotten
really really strict rules of engagement
briefings before we went in so the guys
were a little bit hesitant to let her
rip so that shot I rushed I wound up
hitting the Jeep right on the side walls
between the Gunners legs but that was
enough as soon as the jeep got hit boom
they drove away and they were done and
then these guys started to do a peel and
it was a really organized squared away
good deal so they were peeling behind a
building so that now they were starting
to gain a little bit of distance on us
and they were falling behind this big
building Monte's given me gives me
another round he's like hey I think
they're about at 700 yards now adjust
your dope so I'd made my adjustment from
from where I was just shooting at to 700
and as you know as the they're doing
appeal a guy gets up and runs so there
was a guy running full value
he's running across with the rock RPG so
I shot at him hit way behind him and he
went behind a building then reloaded two
more guys peeled behind the building and
then they were just gone so I held I
held my crosshairs on the edge of that
building were they just gone and a
second later the guy with the RPG steps
back out into my crosshairs and so my
crosshairs are squared up on his pelvis
and I start loading the trigger as he's
taken a knee to shoot the RPG so his
heating he hit the ground when that 50
Cal round hit him in the chest and so we
were shooting the ralphus mark 211 which
is a multi-purpose armor-piercing round
and it explodes when it hit something
hard and the spotters like bro that
thing will hit right up when it hit his
chest
boom down he went and then
then that was it then they got some guys
over there that linguists and they had
loudspeakers on their Humvees and
they're like hey don't shoot at us we're
not taking sides in this whole thing and
that kind of calmed everything down for
the next couple hours and into that day
and then we we watch the guy it's like
life was incredibly cheap there saw a
guy get pushed off a roof we were
watching in the evening we had gotten
someone said like hey that this one
building about two kilometers away
that's when the clan leaders buildings
and we could see guys up there in the
evening and they get that cop there that
makes them all go kind of crazy and we
see guys sitting there like watching the
Sun set up on a roof and then one of
them would start to get animated waving
their arms around like they're arguing
about something then they are all
animated then they were up like beating
each other with clubs hitting each other
with rocks and then it would just stop
and then it would start up again and I
think at least one of those we watched
the guy just get pushed off a roof fall
dead and it's just how they roll and so
this so the first day was pretty mellow
with this all this activity took place
on the second or the third day first day
was mellow second day was uh OHS when
they pulled back and then the third days
when they said no the first day was
mental a second morning is when they
pulled back and then the second day is
when we got in that first firefight and
then it was either that afternoon or the
next day my memory you know it's been 13
years memory slips where they called and
they hasn't been an issue with the guy
they're like hey or two three years but
yeah we'll take it okay I should have
taken more discipline they they hit us
up they're like hey we've got a guy down
here that is close to where we're
getting ready to move some armor and he
has an 84 which is weird because that's
one of our weapons it wasn't an RPG yet
a legit 84 and they'd shot out
and he ran away and came back they're
like he's gonna use it so we want to do
this deal we're gonna have a sniper
initiated kind of assault on this guy so
they sent an lav over to our position me
and the OIC got in and we went and saw
the lieutenant colonel and he's like hey
um here we studied a map he's like hey
here's where the guy is I think a good
spot is this tower there's some recon
guys up there I'm gonna put you up there
with him and then then get this going so
I went up to the tower we moved up to
the tower the guys showed us that what
it was was out there there was a set of
bunkers in alongside of the airfield
that was now controlled by just whoever
and this guy was in one of the bunkers
and then he would come out with like six
or seven other guys and he had eight you
know and they would smoke cigarettes and
he had the 84 and he would they were
watching the US line so they said hey
here's what we want you to do you know
he keeps coming in and out when he comes
out again we want you to shoot him and
then we're gonna have they shifted some
of the light armored vehicles down the
line to where they could go at go at the
bunker with their coax guns and try and
get him in his buddies so we put us up
in the tower there's this a 20 mile an
hour wind just howling full-value
its right to left and then it's from
where I was in the tower
it's a thousand-yard shot so so I got a
bunch of sandbags bunkered my position
up we waited around you know for the guy
to come up he comes up so I take this
thousand-yard shot at a guy in a twenty
mile an hour you know full value
crosswind which at the time there's
probably two or three people in the
world that can make a shot like that and
I'm not one of them I missed and his
buddy
so I didn't hit the guy with the 84 I
hit the guy with the ak-47 standing
three feet to his right because I put in
too much wind and they all dove in the
bunkers then everybody on the line
started shooting the bunkers toward the
bunkers up they called the ceasefire and
the one of those guys survived and it
was the guy that had that 84 but he left
it and he just got up and ran away then
at a later point there was a guys they
were shooting at the elk axes they were
coming in and out and so we we there was
a there was a big cinderblock wall seven
hundred yards away away from the the
airfield there and he was on the other
side of it and there was one cinderblock
missing and he would look through and
shoot through it so I shot at him and
hit the wall right next to the wherever
he was shooting at and I scared him away
and and come back but uh then that was
it then the next day we backed up and
everybody fell back out to the ship the
the Marines ran a great operation
because everything kind of went like
clockwork exactly the way it was
supposed to and it was a good to go then
you went back on the Hellcat you just
said yeah the elk ax came up on the
beach got back in the mill then God back
in the mill van went back out to the
ship and then the final deal was there
was just a strip of the amphibs that
just drove out to sea as they broke down
the final deal and that was it yeah that
was it that was but but then I was like
one of six guys at the time on the West
Coast did it you know been on the
trigger and and been in combat yeah no I
remember it was awesome I was super
stoked and super jealous of course like
every other guy was like which actually
this is it why I did another argh
because it seemed like hey if you're
gonna get some action you need to go
with the Marine Corps in the Arg and go
out and do that that's why myself and
all the other guys that you know all my
old runnin mates we all were like okay
let's do another hour
get back over there let's see let's make
this out what's going to the problem I
mean I had to arts and to combat action
ribbons yeah and then you know it worked
out for a lot of other guys since then
or before that because there were two
the other guys that had rotated through
Somali had been on the art platoon yeah
when you get home you know what was
going on
what were you married at this point I
was I was married to my son's mother and
and when did you get married I don't
what it was it no but not not what year
but like training cell at the time isn't
training cells or time I was after much
of less than a year of marriage or maybe
two years of marriage
yeah and then how did how was that
dealing with you know being gone and
being the team guy marriage
oh he's generally really hard it was
hard it and in it I want to back up
really quick cuz I want to make sure I
point this out before we get into this
next thing and another thing that that
monny told taught me that we kind of
talked about a little bit was he's like
wherever you go run for mayor and he's
just talking about be good to everyone
everywhere you go because they're gonna
go out of their way to take care of you
so like that crew on the Ogden on that
deployment they took great care of us
because he always went out of his way to
be good to everybody you know just to go
back to mommy a little bit it's weird to
think about now right you look back at
what you did now and what you've done
since then which is obviously a ton and
going back to you being there and when I
think about it in my mind about how just
I guess immature is part of the word but
it's beyond just being immature because
I'm not just talking about being
immature in the traditional sense of the
word I'm talking about being combat
immature meaning no one had any combat
right yeah and I think about just having
a guy like Monty who's like level-headed
who's been in some shit before and can
go you know what hey we need to shoot
this guy before he shoots at us that's
just totally sensible thing to say but
if if everyone's cuz
you got these massive all roee briefs
and everyone's being paranoid and you
can't a listen we don't want we don't
want this to escalate and all these
things are in everyone's head yeah and
it's so easy it's kind of like the
detachment when you just go hey you know
what this guy has an RPG they just shot
one at us he's aiming it he's gonna
shoot us again we need to kill this guy
okay go ahead and then instead of you
know dude you're low you're low you know
or whatever just hey you're good load
another round just being calm when I
think about the advantage and how that's
a pretty good performance you know what
you guys was a pretty good performance
with no experience because I think of
how you know what I gained through
experience and the maturity the combat
maturity of seeing things and things
unfolding and being like okay I can
handle this right now or this isn't a
big deal or whatever but man when you're
when you don't have that everyone's all
excited everyone's freaking out and
everything's just magnified and so it's
pretty impressive
and it to me you again you have a guy
like Monty that's just looking at the oh
I see his boss mm-hmm and saying hey we
actually need to kill this guy right now
and and not being like we need to take
this guy out which just escalated in the
oh I see he's thinking oh my god you
know he might say shut up you know
whatever yeah just going hey man we need
to take this guy out just just having
that mentality is is so important and I
don't know how well would you guys have
done if he wasn't there I don't think
we'd had done as well we we might not
even been in the position where we shot
yeah yeah um yeah cuz he just carried us
through that whole thing he had a funny
thing he taught us he goes if you're
ever really excited and and he may have
put this out to you too over the radio
he goes if you try to talk like you have
a Southern drawl it'll slow you down
yeah and he goes and you won't have a
Southern drawl by the way but it'll slow
you down and he told us of a case that
there was some officers in a high-speed
chase and they were so calm over the
radio people didn't believe that they
were in a high-speed chase except for
the rep the speed at which they are
going out we just passed this
we just passed this street we just
passed this street because they were
cool as cucumbers you know I'm freaking
out
yeah that's awesome no it's it's
definitely just it's cool to hear that
story and you tell probably told me that
story 21 years ago or something like
that and I actually heard you briefed
that story to a bunch of people at a dog
and pony show and it was really epic to
tell that story but to hear the full
actually um did you ever give me that
detailed of a debrief but it's awesome
that at that time no combat experience
it's like okay here's what we're gonna
do and that's a good lesson for everyone
man detached stay calm look at what's
going on and it all does go back to the
fact that you were in that position
probably had something to do with the
fact that you that you know you were
running for mayor or you know monney as
a platoon chief was running for mayor
and building relationships and hanging
out with Marines and teaching them
whatever and getting giving them some
gear and well you know just doing those
things that you're building
relationships with the rest of the team
instead of being an arrogant jerk to
everyone because you think you're better
than them absolutely because there was
another unit that had 50 Cal sniper
rifles that didn't get to come well
there you go yeah there it is okay so
now you get back and how long was that
deploy is that just a six month or well
they they were already deployed so I
three and a half months with them
because I replaced it got a guy that got
in trouble got it and then but okay so
now we were starting to dive into a
marital scenario yeah so you got a kid
already you got a kid my son's mother
was pregnant when I went on that
deployment so he was that was in
February and he was born in September 95
so yeah I came back and then it was one
of those situations where
me being gone all the time didn't help
but me being home all the time didn't
help either and it in and so we just
parted ways and it was it was hard for
me not to have my son in my house but it
it was it was the best thing because me
and his mom just didn't get along and
then this is at the point at the same
time this is this one you got out this
is right with it are we got divorced
right after I got out which did you get
out with the vision in mind that you're
gonna be able to save this thing or did
you get out with a vision in mind like
no this is already too far so no yeah I
got out she she wanted to like hey I
want you around more you're gone too
much it's you know this isn't good
get that but then say we got out I got
out and then and she realized that she
really doesn't last much I can't blame
her so so then then we ended up
separating or or get you know going
through the neutral and getting out oh I
was gonna go work for a guy doing some
kind of investment stuff huh because
that makes a lot of sense yeah there was
no plan it wasn't thought through the
smartest thing I did was the day the day
I got out I enlisted in there or or I
joined the reserve so I was in the SEAL
team five reserve teams so I did that
for a year and a half and then when all
it dust settled and with with the you
know who's gonna have custody and where
my son's gonna live it was like what am
i doing I'm only happy when I go to do
my reserve drill yeah and so I'm like
hey I want to go back on active duty at
the time they were critically
undermanned 4e sixes so they're like
boom so the timing like my timing I've
been so lucky for my timing like being
on the quarterback that one day I
checked into trade at in August of 2001
into the sniper cell and then you know
the planes hit the towers and then the
teams are just off to the races
yeah did you when you when you were
civilian or whatever you were a
reservists civilian how long did it take
you to realize that this was a bad call
and I'm gonna jump forward like when you
would have guys that were saying they
were gonna get out at 13 years or nine
years or whatever
did you you know what would you tell him
about that oh you mean later
yeah like later like because you know
you I would you know when I was well my
you know once I was an officer and I
would have friends that were like eh
able to get out and you know I'd say the
experience I had was I went to college
right and when I went to college for
three years and when I came back I was
like the main thing I learned in college
was never ever ever ever get out of the
teams ever because in dealing with other
people it was just so horrible and
especially I mean like you and me who
literally spent our whole adult life in
a platoon you get out of business you
know with normal people and you're like
what are they everyone doing once have
what why is this even happening
it's just nothing makes yeah there's a
lot of awkward silences no one gets your
jokes and it was what I usually tell
guys is like hey I got broken service
and you're gonna once you get out you're
gonna miss this beer group mmm you'll
miss this job and I don't think you're
gonna make that much more money yeah and
but I never I always tried the soft sell
yeah
hey and I would tell guys here's my
phone number
do not lose my phone number and if you
decide you want to come back and please
call me I will you know figure out how
to get you wherever I'm at or back in
and I've done that for at least two or
three guys ya know it's a I know it's a
hard decision for guys to make and and
usually and and sometimes it's um what
is that it's an emotional decision well
completely because they had a bad
deployment they didn't like someone or
their wife's Madden or whatever and then
make that emotional decision when in
fact the teams can take care of you -
you know the teams can go hey look we
know you need some downtime you're gonna
go to buds and be an instructor or
whatever you know for three years you
know you can get your kid through high
school or whatever so the teams does a
good job usually of taking care of of
the people you know taking care of team
guys but sometimes you know people they
have the grass is greener situation
again in the 90s we're playing we're
training for a big game that we're not
going to do and so there was a loss of
job satisfaction there yeah and and who
knows where Anna still be what
trajectory we were on had these wars not
started yeah that's a good question
that's a scary question wait so what you
do when you got back in so you went oh
my god when went into trade net just got
stood up and I went into the stand up
those 2001 that's luckier uh-huh and so
I got in there they're like hey we're
gonna do a sniper cell and we're gonna
be dedicated to this which is something
that wasn't replicated on the other
coast I was like oh man are you kidding
me I'm just gonna do sniper stuff all
the time
yeah and throw me in that Burpee and you
were the perfect literally the perfect
guy and they probably were just
overjoyed to have you come and it did it
with a real world experience yeah which
is serious at that time because no one
had it yeah and so it allows you to say
stuff to people and they're gonna listen
to you like like we were talking about
earlier where if a guy tells you to get
your hair cut and he's a goofball and
ain't done anything just like yeah
whatever
and and then so when you run to that
sniper course are you guys now was that
the sniper course no the sniper course
was already stood up so now what we're
doing this is what we kind of ended up
with that trade net which is you guys
are going out to training you're
implementing sniper things into the
overall training and you're doing
specialized training for the snipers
that's what you ended up that yeah we so
for a little bit we were
still running the sniper course I think
till like two thousand two or three and
then doing the sustainment training and
so you know we developed the urban
course the long-range target
interdiction course which they they have
a different variant on it now but um you
know that's uh the land it was under
land warfare and the land warfare oh I
see at the time was a Warrant Officer
Prichard Doug Pritchard who's an awesome
dude he still works in shooting to this
day and we got a lot of cool stuff done
like we got the the ballistic computers
which made you know shooting a whole lot
more predictable and then we could get
guns ready to go in a lot less rounds
because we had these computers that did
it and we did a lot of good research and
development and tactics that we could
push directly to the platoons which I
mean nsw snipers are like the mainstay
group I think of of snipers in the world
yeah I'm not saying that we're better
than anybody because everybody's really
good but we've had a really rich history
of employing snipers and doing stuff
with with snipers you know as you well
know yeah yeah and speaking of that how
did you end up doing an augment because
you augmented to Ramadi right right in
what year was that 2005 so there was
there was some of that video that got
released of nose guy kitten that first
couple snipers or whatever it was in
Ramadi and the common or at the time saw
that and he goes that's it and they they
had a piece of gear that was supposed to
help us detect enemy snipers and so they
bought some they gave it to us to test
out real quick
and then we got to take it forward with
SEAL team seven to go hey here's this
new gear here's how you use it and and
then it also gave us the ability to get
get straight over there and kind of into
the fights
we team seven had just moved into the
the shark base there at Ramadi and then
we went in there with them and they long
did you stay there for six weeks how was
it awesome it's so cool so cool I didn't
I didn't want to come back but you know
you come from the strand I didn't do the
workup my guys didn't do the workup and
there's other guys doing PSD and they're
like hey what's up with these dudes who
aren't even at our team and they're
going out on sniper missions so it's
it's not cool it's combat tourism and I
was super lucky that we were able to you
know be there as long as we were and
then it was just like yeah it's time to
go you did a turnover with the guys that
were there in other words you taught
them how to use the system and yeah
we're like a ops with them when it got
to go out and some ops with them got to
go on a lot of date I like my favorite
thing to do was go out on daytime
presence patrols with the army or the
Marine Corps because that's was so fun
you know and then so we we could took to
get embedded in a daytime presence it
was a one slide 5wc
which which for the planning cycle it's
really easy it's like gonna be approved
no problem and then if you wanted to mix
it up that's that's where it was
happening out on the streets with the
guys that are walking around using
themselves as bait so we would balance
between going out with the Marines and
going out with the the army and and in
both cases it was awesome but I I really
have a soft spot in my heart for the
Marine Corps because my dad was Marine
but when you're in a Marine Patrol it
it's like being a part of a big huge
beast that's just walking down the
street waiting for someone to bump into
it and then they just turn and go after
it and were you guys setting up a
bounding over watches during that or we
just going on patrol of us we would gone
but so so the reason that we would go on
patrol is so we could we could look for
positions to put up snipe
over watches and the sniper over watches
were to catch guys placing IEDs out in
the road and they'd already gotten like
three or four cuz some guys went out on
a really good op you know a guy that we
both know and they pick up two guys who
are digging in our ID and then there was
another couple where they got and they
were they're having an impact for a
little bit so well that meant a lot to
the Marine Corps in the Army when they
are losing guys all the time to IEDs and
then and you know hardly ever to the IND
and placers actually get captured or
killed so yeah when they're getting laid
out in the streets by snipers man those
guys were excited about it and in their
time and then then then you know you had
that whole thing going on with the
populace because they they began to
believe that every building had an
american sniper in it which is a good
that's exactly what you're denying them
freedom of movement and they gotta look
over their shoulders before they place
you know one one of those one five five
rounds in the road yeah yeah so you get
done with that how much longer after
that did you go to team three
immediately I got back from that and
then checked out a trade yet and checked
into SEAL Team three for my platoon
chiefs law and that was an interesting
ride that true Buick isn't so now I'm at
SEAL team 3 common task unit bruiser and
you're a SEAL team three in your task
unit and there's that that one there was
some drama in that one right in fact I
mean life and I wrote about it in
extreme ownership because this is the
story and extreme ownership of when the
political one of the platoon commanders
and the task unit commander did not
couldn't get along and unfortunately
they could not come to any kind of
agreement of how to work together in
fact you know that the skipper said hey
you guys got the weekend figure out how
to how are you gonna deploy together and
I think they could have come back and
said look you know he goes there I'll go
somewhere else we'll we'll figure it out
but they both came back in and kind of
stuck to their guns which is no I don't
want to work with him
I don't work with him and the skipper
fired him both actually yeah that was
crazy that was a horrible like that had
been brewing for a long time and so just
that drama is so horrible to deal with
like Vic when and they're they're both
good guys yeah but it's just this drama
brewed and then there is all this crazy
uncertainty and you know who's gonna get
fired what's gonna happen as a result of
that and so you know I'm glad the
Admiral made to call that he did and it
it worked and then we the guy you took
over as of the tea you commit so we are
a OIC went over became they always oh I
am I see our assistant officer in charge
became though I see another platoon
there is an officer you read a
counseling chit for in the real early
podcast that the new task unit commander
the first thing he did the first day was
sit down and give him a counseling Chet
yeah that's good leadership yeah he's
like hey here's what you're doing wrong
here's what right looks likes laid it
all out for him and and that was it and
then he he was super direct gave us our
left and rights and then we were just
like I was like I remember thinking
personally this is awesome yeah he's
strict but that I I don't care if he if
you tell me where my left and rights are
especially you know when that guys
especially because when you're coming in
I've said this many times when you're
coming into a situation where there's
there's problems right
there's definitely problems when the OIC
and the task unit commander just got
fired there are problems you have to
come in and kind of set down you have to
lay down the law a little bit it's not
like you know if I roll into a tasking
that they're doing great and the one of
the guy had a family emergency and he
had to leave and I roll in and it's like
okay I'm not gonna lay down the law and
a bunch of guys that are doing well I'm
gonna go in there and say hey
we work with you guys and then over time
if there's things that need to be
adjusted cool maybe they don't need to
be adjusted but whatever it's different
when you roll into a situation where
things are not good and then you have to
lay down the law the other thing that's
very important about what you just said
is sometimes people are sometimes from a
leadership perspective you don't feel
comfortable giving direction because
you're like well I don't really know
what's going on and but it's it's
important to think about times in your
life or times in your career when you
didn't get good direction from the
person you're working for and how just
you don't really know what's happening
and you don't feel you don't you can't
predict what's gonna happen and so you
you just feel kind of a little bit lost
and then you think to yourself man I
just wish the boss would just tell us
what the hell he wants and so that's
kind of what happened there's a ball the
new boss comes in and says hey here's
what's going on here's what we're gonna
do hey you guy that's all jacked up
here's what you need to improve and
everyone instead of what in your mind
you might think hey I'm gonna piss
everyone off if I come in and lay down
the law at this you've got to remember
that people have been wondering what the
hell's going on for six months for a
year they don't know who's in charge
everything's a disaster no decisions are
being made you come in and people are
gonna thank God thank you for telling me
what the hell you want I I'm tired of
playing a guessing game every Monday
morning about who's my boss and what
direction were going into so that's
that's an important part to remember now
I am definitely there's a dichotomy of
course because you can come in and you
can start barking orders and everyone
just says well who are you where'd you
come from you don't know what you're
talking about you haven't been here shut
up and of course they won't say that to
you they'll just undermined what you're
trying to do and cause all kinds of you
know just just try and usurp you with
whatever they can so that's problem but
what I'm saying is there is a a happy
medium and there are times when you lean
towards being laying down the law and
there's times where you lean towards
being more loose and you got to figure
out where that's gonna be depending on
the situation you're diving into and so
the advantage that the guy coming in had
was he'd been watching this situation
for a while and he knew everybody so
sometimes when you come somewhere new
it's it's
maybe keep just listen before you start
making some major adjustments or
something like that and but that would
have just prolonged the angst all of us
were feelings and he came in he had a
big brief it was and after that I felt
like someone had taken 40 pounds out of
my rucksack yeah because you finally
knew where you were going who was in
charge and what at least the near-future
meant which think you get rid of what
the near-future
you get with you get rid of the
certainty of the near future you get rid
of who's in charge you get rid of what's
gonna happen you take all that away and
you're just left uncertain and that's a
horrible feeling you know probably the
worst well yeah I think from from a
perspective of being led yeah having no
idea what's gonna happen is the worst I
talk about that example of rats in a
cage and how the rats on one side of the
cage they just get electrocuted randomly
from the floor and but the electrocution
isn't very strong the other side of the
cage has a stronger elect electrocution
shock but there's a little light that
comes on that lets them know that you're
about to get shocked and rats prefer to
know that they're gonna get shocked even
if it's more often and even if it's
stronger they just prefer to know that
it's coming as opposed to be just
randomly getting shocked and you don't
know why it's gonna happen and that's
basically where you where your task unit
was because there was I mean it was like
a public - it's like a public everyone
kind of knew it was going on at least
after about six months you know I would
say after all of us being at the team
for about six months it was readily
apparent that's that's for sure and you
guys actually that one of the pieces of
collateral damage that was Mike Sorelli
it Mike Sorelli he they didn't know what
to do with him because I forget what the
internal conflict but there was internal
conflict with Mike Sorelli
and meaning that I don't even know what
it was but so they said hey Jocko you
want this guy and like affirmative and
then you came up to me and I was like
you know this guy and you're like yes
he's awesome
cool and you know there was other people
that were saying oh he's this and he's
that and of course the other people I'm
like okay and I listen to him and then I
was like thinking okay well that's why I
think I asked you like hey what's this
guy's deal yeah like he's awesome you're
you're stoked and I was like cool good
to go
yeah Mike was awesome yeah and and he
wasn't geez obviously he still is
awesome and then you guys did that
workup and then you guys deployed over -
while I was in Ramadi you guys were over
and uh oh um in Guam yeah so I tell you
what if it hadn't been contrasted it was
an amazing deployment like we nobody got
in trouble we did a lot of great stuff
which is a big problem in Guam guys just
getting in trouble and you know the fit
the problem was that we guys were
hearing in real-time like hey they just
got the first carl gustaf kills in
Ramadi and hey this is happening and and
I remember one day we were on in we're
in Thailand on an exercise staying in a
five-star hotel and guys are all gloomy
and I to get everybody at the side of
the pool at the five-star hotel and I'm
like listen I want to be there too it's
not gonna happen we have to put the
mission first our mission is to be here
and this is an amazing experience I
guarantee you're gonna remember for the
rest of your life you guys got to stop
whining yeah stop worrying about it and
of course all the guys always joke about
the fact that when you're sitting in a
sweaty overwatch position it's 118
degrees like okay we just spend a week
in Thailand right now by the pool I know
whoa and then when they used to do that
rip yeah where you'd go to Iraq and then
halfway through come back to Guam the
problem is in Guam they'd be like guys
would get back here and they wouldn't
want to do any work and they weren't
they weren't focused on what was going
on you know but then that's the mission
has got to come first and the mission
isn't always something that you can tell
stories about hey I got the ride
elephants I got to sit on a croc
Isles back uh I got great for damn of
them either of those yeah
I was good it was interesting to like
going back to the workup it was a good
contrast for my especially for my
officers to kind of see like I'd be
watching this unfold and you know I had
stoner and Lafe and I'd be you know we
would talk about it be like bro this is
what's going on fellas look at this look
what's happening here and it was a good
contrast for them to see because it made
it so obvious like why you have to work
together why these relationships we have
inside the tasking are so important why
we need if you have an issue you bring
it up you bring it to me why it's not
gonna freak me out why we're gonna talk
about it why you know Lafe always says
in sedona would have told you the same
thing the Flav fought like hey I'd like
to try this a different way
I'd be like cool how do you want to try
it go let's let's make it happen I don't
care I don't I don't care what happens
as long as it makes us win so there was
a really cool for me unfortunately it
was not cool for you to be in a position
where I could look and use the
leadership failures in that task unit
and the other interesting thing was like
you talked about those two guys you're
like hey they're both good guys I've
actually know both those guys and would
be getting debriefed by both of them
like both of them would be telling me
what the other person was doing and man
you just be thinking guys instead of
telling me go tell each other go talk to
each other it didn't happen yeah the
enemy's outside the wire not Owens yeah
and what will you what was what were you
when you're looking at my task you know
what were you thinking when we're to
work up and stuff you guys are gonna go
to Iraq and we're we're gonna go to pay
comm that's fine I mean that's that is
we knew where we were laid out and how
we were manned and it was all good to go
it wasn't like we were kicking cans oh
no it's like okay well that's how it's
gonna be
well they proposed they made up the
command made a proposal uh-huh that
was early on as a matter of fact I was
at Nylund dirt so that was our first
block returning the command made a
proposal that we kind of disassembled
the task units and reassemble them in a
way that was more fair with regards to
who's been to Iraq and who's not and
they made this proposal and so they made
this proposal to us it was to me
personally to the task unit commanders
as a matter of fact
hey that we can rearrange this thing and
that way guys haven't been can get to go
it was like the fair ferry was coming
out right and I mean I was just like
there's no possible way but I went back
to Nylund and I sat down with the
platoon commanders and the platoon
chiefs and the the my senior chief and I
was like hey here's what they're
proposing they're proposing that we
could disassemble these task units and
we could reassemble them so that guys
that haven't been to Iraq can go and
then the other guys that had been to
Iraq that have combat experience and
there's all those things you can layer
on top of that like hey cuz guys will
say well I can't get promoted if I
haven't been to it you know what I mean
like all these things they layer all
these things on top of it because that's
a crazy proposal if you think about it
yes but also if you think about it
that's how much it means to guys that
they want to go and so now this is 2005
so there was still guys that had been on
shore view over there that were cycling
back in never been to combat and they
missed the 2003-2004 deployments and
they're thinking eh this is ridiculous
and it's what you talked about earlier
job dissatisfaction you know you've been
in the teams for 12 years and you and
there's a big war going on and you don't
get to go that is the kind of thing you
have to consider and think how can we
take care of the troops you know take
care of the guys because we want it they
all want to go to war and there's a war
going on and yet we're gonna send them
some of them to not war but I came I
came back in Island I was said hey guys
here's the proposals I recommend we they
also offered it's a competition it's a
competition and it was really just a
competition between my task unit and
your task unit because the other task
unit they they actually didn't that task
unit didn't go to Iraq on the last
so they said look you guys get to go
this time for sure and then it was
between us too and they said we can
either split up up a lot do that or make
it a competition and this commanding
officer will decide who's gonna go based
on performance and I told my guys I was
like I say we go for performance and we
do the best we can and we will probably
crush everyone and if we don't we don't
deserve to go and we'll go do our job in
panco and of course all the guys were
like hell yes that's what we did
sure and and you know like when I was a
CMC at Team five and I was doing my
Manning the hard fast rule was if you
went to pay come last time you are not
going to pay comm again and then so
those guys could get a chance and then
some of this some of the guys that went
to CENTCOM went back but in the end when
I'm building seal leaders
I need guys that have been everywhere I
need guys that have had the Paycom
experience and understand they're mature
enough to go all the mission is first
and then guys that have been exposed to
combat so they know what that's all
about
yeah you know and and when you got done
so when you got done with that potential
then where'd you go so because I didn't
because I was in Paycom I I made a deal
with the new command master chief and
and I said hey I know I'm stepping down
but I want to go to CENTCOM so can I
stay here in the capacity of as the ops
chief for one troop which was the in my
guy who is the OIC a my platoon who
fleeted Jack Riggins fleed up to be the
the troop commander and I'm like hey can
I can I stay and go to CENTCOM now cuz
he was gonna go to CENTCOM as is uh his
his ops chief and they're like sure and
it's I'm actually stepping down Tony did
the same thing and then Tony and I both
made senior chief and they're like hey
it's time for you to go he's and they
sent us over to the senior enlisted
Academy and then we went over to SEAL
Team seven together
which worked out great yeah that later
and you know what um the great part that
you just mentioned is like a three-hour
conversation yeah which we don't aren't
gonna have right now because look the
second part of your career or the part
that would if yeah we'll get into this
we'll do another one well just will this
role do another podcast we'll record it
like tomorrow and that's gonna follow
you into Afghanistan back to Iraq again
more time more training more tours
combat tours tours as senior enlisted
tours as the command master chief
towards as an ops Master Chief
I mean there's a lot of massive stuff to
talk about from here on out so we'll do
that we'll record that tomorrow good
Jack echo yes while we're waiting for
the next podcast mm-hmm I know have you
probably have some suggestions on what
we can do instead of just sitting around
and waiting there's probably some ways
that we could get better yes I do how do
you have permission first thing is you
to Jason jujitsu yes dave-o I'm a one
stripe white belt and there you go so
and so we know what did what did it feel
like when you got the bug when did you
get on the mat for the first time
legitimately thinking all right I want
to know what this is all about okay so
the the same Master Chief
that taught us in Guam Oh Steve Bailey
Steve Bailey I trained with him for a
little bit in Guam and then just got
distracted you know like talking my
teeth into a little bit but then it's
like a year ago started training out in
East County yeah yeah and it was just
awesome but I I was like a spaz I match
it's like what am I supposed to they're
like relax I'm like what am I just
supposed to lose I'll leave you right
now
the 49:49 so everybody that asks
51 can I start jujitsu um 39 can I start
to do - um whatever age you are the
answer is yes you can start jujitsu we
recommend that you calm down without
starting I wanted to roll these once you
relax a relaxation level right now if I
was because I haven't read like six
months
why be I probably spaz out for a hot
minute and then figure it out but uh
yeah because you you're torn you don't
know what you're doing but you just
don't want to roll over and like oh
you're having my arm yeah so you just
put a triangle and know that it's a it's
a it's easier it's a sweat situation
that unfolds that you know is going to
unfold that you know is not the correct
thing to do and there's no way you can
stop yourself from doing it like you
just said someone's gonna arm lock you
you know what's gonna happen you could
just scale okay you know what I'm just
got me I'm gonna let him but no you
cannot stop yourself from gorilla
gripping your other hand and hanging on
for dear life for an extra 12 seconds
before you tap there's no possible way
to overcome that it's just common so
yeah you have to do that but hopefully
you can make through that you can make
it through that transition you fairly
quickly yeah it's amazing for my kids -
Wow kids it's a beautiful thing
it's a beautiful thing for kids yeah it
seems like the spazzing thing even as
you get it I mean I would say that it
happens less and less but they'll be
like momentary spaz situations even at
like the top level huh where you kind of
got to stay calm I mean everyone through
all I'll run into it where I got stay
conscious of it oh I see the danger
coming and it's coming pretty quick you
got to think well I in my sister I'll
think through it and I'll be way more
successful rather than Lycos pass
through it so now I'm more tired and
it's still coming kind of I hate to say
this too cuz it's horrible for me to put
this out there but there are times when
you have to spaz to escape something
Dean Lister will if I do that he just
like he
he it's worth it even if I get out it's
worth it that I spaz because it can make
fun of me yeah good bass he's just
making fun of me because we know we both
know the only reason that I got out of
whatever he just did to me is because I
kicked and squirm didn't spazzed out and
he wasn't ready for it
mm-hmm and then I got out yeah it'll
work out but a huge cost so there's like
there's too little the additional
elements to a successful spaz escape or
whatever one you gotta be at least
somewhat strong like you can't like a
smaller person like spazzing is way less
effective even at eye level there's that
and then when you're strong when you're
a strong person and you spaz
successfully you're way more tired way
more tired so you get a person where you
put them in a spazzing state like two
three three times in a row yeah no more
oh yeah you can't spend more than I
don't make you give a Mack spaz rep
Sephora after that you're the next one
there will be no spaz left yes real urge
it's passes there's no time no space
left and which brings you back to went
back early on as a white belt or
something like this where you know it's
spaz spaz spaz and they feel the effects
of three spasms in a row thank you and
you're like dang this is exhausting yeah
when you start that's just who is just
spazzing and more especially and then
it's like the opposite of when you know
wait in the beginning there's these
small moments where you don't spaz yeah
and then when you get better there's
small moments when you do spaz yes and
then when you're really good I mean very
seldom do I make bean spaz yeah I do
occasionally though it's a little little
little little crazy and you know I end
up in a way to where that's why these
little is smaller guys when they're
super advanced I don't think they ever
spaz ever cause it's like been
unproductive for them right every
attempted spaz is gonna be like
unsuccessful you know any kind it's a
spectrum obviously so their whole thing
is just thinking through the thing Andy
Berke sure he does this his form of
space
is like this silent spaz he pretends
it's not happening
oh yeah yeah but it is happening over
yeah he's doing these like in little
movements it's there's only one
technique that it could truly be called
that's as fast but he acts like it
wasn't he's real cool yeah he's real
cool he's acting like that was you know
just like any offense that he knows one
of his things I'm on to you and Ebert
yeah I know what's up that's a good tip
I'm gonna look out for it I don't know
if I've ever made Andy space but you
know I'm gonna be looking out for it
nonetheless when you're in jujitsu we
all need Aggie
if we're doing it and I'm not saying you
have to do kit you should do geek I
think she responded yeah do both that's
the recommended boat if you trained Gino
gay both oh yeah the place we were
training at they did both yeah so one
night was noogie the other night was gay
was awesome that's not origin jeez
they're awesome
Oh until you're in a game so some people
they they may or may not be looking hey
what kind of gear should I get there you
go just like this gartner set or Jinky
100% best skis factually by the Jason
Gardner with the orange and get plugged
comment straight off the top ropes
yeah he just pulled that out of nowhere
yeah he's a Yankee and Nokia by the way
which is the finest key in America and
many people say the finest ski in the
world yeah I I say that I say that -
yeah and it is made in America by the
way yeah so yeah anyway when you go to
origin main comm that's where you get it
you can also get other stuff like rash
guards t-shirts for the no key if your
name is echo Charles no I shouldn't say
that if your name is not Jocko willing
you can get joggers mm-hmm because I
don't look like normal I don't I don't
know what to say I look you don't man I
don't I don't feel man yeah joggers are
not for me yeah
is it him what is that Brad you just
don't match so here this is what
actually this is what it is uh-huh
okay jogger you know with joggers are
right do you have orders already skinny
no okay yeah there's so they're skinny
Jesus in wet pants kind of tapered we're
not
they're really tapered a little bit of a
would he call like a drop crotch a
little bit for like a lot of roomy in
the hips area kind of thing do you think
they're functional yes but I think the
big push is a style thing because
there's like skinny jeans and all this
stuff so it's kind of like a functional
thing yes but it's a style thing that's
the part you don't match you attitude
you especially anything that says skinny
or thin or trim fit or what Brad that's
not you that's somebody else so yeah
that's not gonna mess with you at all in
fact even to you know people have like
real fitted jeans Yeah right like real
fitted yeah yeah it's a tight I'm gonna
say that yes I fit it mm-hmm
you should not do that either no that's
not you huh it's just not you but the
weird thing is the world changes right
the fashion changes
I just keep wearing the same stuff yeah
at some point is what I we're gonna come
back
well fashion wise me but actually know
what I wear this is the thing I think
what I wear doesn't it doesn't state
just what hey you can't say hey this
guy's wearing a t-shirt and pair of
jeans you could wear t-shirt a pair of
jeans in 1950 1960 1970 never I never go
out of style quality never goes out of
style yeah and actually even to be more
precise since yours
you don't go for fashion at all you go
for like this functionality kind of
situation so if if anything you do is
like fashion yeah which I know some
fashion stuff in your past like maybe
hair styles etc that's why if you see
old pictures of Jocko with his hair you
believe don't be like you know kind of
the thing that's the that's the guy that
Jason was talking about earlier that's
me like we were I like that like hey
we're in the teams we have long hair
yeah yeah push the handle of why you
care long as I could get it yeah dizzy
and now the fashion thing to look good
but your clothing wise you'll never go
fashion so you'll never go out of style
because since the fashion is the thing
that revolves and goes out of style
origen jeans I got like the final kind
of cut and everything you know they're
legit so that's another thing they're
it's not it's not a fashion
right their origin genes well they're
not mutually um SaLuSa 'v either so
fortunately they're strong they're
flexible they're durable don't go to
stuff right that stuff's not gonna
stylus or it's not so there we go
origin genes we're are in production
with origin genes in production at this
time so check the website Origin main
comm if you want to get some genes or if
your name is not jock a willing you can
get pair of joggers the jumpers are good
that's the thing where I guys I wasn't
down for the joggers Pete told me is he
opened my open my little like mind or
whatever I put him on I was like dang
these are comfortable but man they're
skinny they're thin
you know they're there it's they're
tight you know they had a specific look
that I wasn't very accustomed to but and
Pete's noticed it he was like yeah
they're like you know you gonna use like
Jocko that they're probably not for
Jocko but you pull him off that's what
Pete said to me I hope he was like Dean
like honest with it but yeah ever since
then I was like okay maybe I can do this
so I only warm at camp so as I go I
might not wear these at home but where
am i camp and then it camp I was like
dang these are good too and when you job
they're way better than regular
sweatpants so I'm like all these are
good and they're like super comfortable
too because you know the continent
thingies or whatever and then I'd wear
I'm at home and that's all I would wear
now I kind of switched over to that
whole thing how are the pocket is all
kinds of life-changing things happen on
in this podcast wait like one of them is
Echo Charles switching to joggers be
noted wait pockets like what for like
functionality you're like for my
everyday carry so I'm going down to the
store and the joggers yeah I would say
like any other sort of sweatpants
situation you know they had pockets on
either side right yeah
no regular sweatpants don't have pockets
bro
yeah okay you're talking about I'm
talking about you know like gym coach
from 1979
no they're not that if they have pockets
for sure I gotta tell you I saw those
boots online and I'm pretty excited
right yeah I open the gun mentioning
that now we're making them we're making
yeah I have a very little and yeah
they're awesome
oh you look pair of those two I'm
perfect hey man you got another one your
one like one degree separation from
getting all the new stuff to where
you're at really cuz it feels like 180
man you know I'm over here looking
online at stuff anyway also mulk right
mokrane Jason we talked earlier you just
what's your milk recipe morning recipe
okay so I get up in the morning brew 20
ounces of coffee i grind up the beans do
it in the French press I add a little
bit of stevia
I'm just wheat in it but it's not gonna
spike my insulin then I put some coconut
milk in there or no coconut oil
grass-fed butter about a tablespoon of
that some MCT oil a scoop of vanilla
malt I hit that with a stick blender oh
I do not have to eat until like 1:00 or
2:00 in the afternoon I get all my fat
in early in the morning so I got a
stress getting good fat in and doing
this is awesome that's an advance take
are the kids on the milk train they are
we and is it if you tried strawberry
milk didn't strawberry warrior kid
strawberry no we haven't we've been
doing the chocolate bro um hot chocolate
yeah the hot chocolate sauce and iris
has been making the pancakes she's just
using it and mixing straight-up pancakes
oh yes X was talking about it the other
day
there's a guy in Lang it was like yeah
more pancakes it's like taking this a
good idea so I just added them basically
replaced like us portion of percentage
of the pancake mix with a milk I thought
I don't know what pancakes are even made
of coz I haven't had them in so long
yeah that's just hey that's on you and
you're kind of missing out on that one
cuz it did they work out really good
yeah okay so we got the mold by the way
we're on that we're on mint I'm on mint
and I'm actually in this whole deal now
when I'm having
mint peanut butter I don't really I
don't really like the flavor vanilla as
I've mentioned on here so I don't have
that but the strawberry to the warrior
kids strawberry milk which Brian is
working on the adult strawberry milk
the vanilla like I'm not a big manila
fan either but it just mixes so well so
like when iris is making smoothies this
is vanilla milk and there I put it in my
coffee because the mint chocolate chip
doesn't work it's my favorite like okay
I get to have dessert and that's exactly
what it is it scratches that itch when
it comes along that's the thing man I
went out last night I had a legit steak
legit that Ragland OB and I still was
needed a little something I needed or
something because they sell this thing
at Raglan called the illegal which is a
giant chocolate chip cookie and cooked
in a cast iron thing it's massive and
then they put vanilla ice cream on it
which is the only time I like vanilla
and the vanilla ice cream is all melting
is just ridiculous but obviously that's
not part of the program so I left Raglan
OB without eating and illegal and I went
home and I'm like I still need some kind
of a little theater so I went peanut
butter on with peanut butter milk and I
just didn't I did it like a scoop and a
half with a little like a half a shaker
of water I drank that thing it was so
good I was sitting there saying this is
a milkshake if this is a milkshake it's
freaking ridiculous you know so they're
yes sir and they added protein let's not
forget that yeah for the end and don't
forget the probiotic microbiome yeah we
haven't even gotten to your whole health
scenario because would you say you're 50
years old a 51/49 for 250 this year and
you're getting after it
I feel great you feel awesome walking
around it like 157 and in before I had
you know before I adjusted my diet and
everything I was 193 and then all kinds
of inflammation and everything hurt and
just crap you know it's all just dialed
in yeah I remember when you were first
going down
path because our wives were hiking and
you and I met somewhere and we you were
just talking about like the you were
starting down this path and coming home
from deployment - yeah so as I was like
for you this is my last deployment I
don't have deployments to go on and get
back in shape so I'm gonna have to stick
with it and yeah so those supplements
join warfare twice a day two in the
morning and two in the evening and that
the turmeric is amazing yeah yeah krill
oil in the morning every morning and
then usually uh any time I'm gonna do
something the discipline go the
basically to go yeah JP said the other
day when he took the discipline go he
could he could see people's thoughts
anyways get all the stuff at uh or
Jemaine calm sorry yes take a really
long time oh good also chuckles door
it's called choco Store so choco
store.com you understand and yeah
there's if you want to represent this
linkle's freedom this is where you can
get your shirts hoodies hats trucker
hats flex fit checkouts left flex me it
I can go either way
oh yes fence Walker they know he's it
both sides right yeah when you can adapt
and adjust what either way that always
got to have a role in it though I'm not
a flat bill black guy yeah that's
actually streams coming from a
California iein aversive because that
app that's like in the last couple
decades or something that was a not yeah
Jack yeah either way there you go
chocolate store that's where you can get
them or sorry chocolate store calm also
women stuff on there as well yeah if you
want to represent while on the path
that's where you go it's good also
jakka white tea mmm if you deadlifting
and you're like tired of your like 500
pound deadlift tired retiree
which yeah you know I can see how you'd
be tired of that oh and you want it to
go up to 8,000 pounds chocolate white
tea and it happens to taste good and it
happens to be USD a organic certified
yeah organic organic
yes that's a good one now that adds a
kind of a little spin
because people used to say to me like
did you refer a picture that you'd be
making tea and it's kind of funny you
know and I got whatever but now it's
like next level did you ever picture
that you'd be making organic tea oh yeah
that is kind of a different thing maybe
I'll be wearing joggers soon as the
whole world going crazy if you don't
subscribe to this podcast which is
shocking to me but now we have reports
from the field of people that listen to
167 podcasts and haven't subscribed to
it and so now echo has made it clear
that you need to subscribe also don't
forget about the the warrior kid podcast
you on the warrior kid podcast oh yeah
that's like yes have the kids memorized
him yet
they love it I mean pretty much yeah
yeah I've been lagging I don't get him
out as much as I can
part of it is because I like really like
doing those stories from Uncle Jake
mm-hmm and they take a little bit more
time and so I need to invest the time
the cute I should just do the q and A's
as well but anyways warrior kid podcast
if you want to get your kid on the pot
on the path and what you want you and I
were talking about earlier of how your
kids just don't really want to listen to
you they listen to Uncle Jake yeah
absolutely just listen to Uncle Jake
absolutely
I had another Master Chief East Coast
Master Chief come out and came to the
gym and he's like bro and I never I
didn't know you know he's just like
another guy he's Coast Guard that I
didn't know and he's like he's like bro
your book your little warrior kid books
he said you got my kid I he's 11 years
old
everything I did for 11 years to get him
to do push-ups and pull-ups failed he
goes he read that book he's like I can't
thank you cuz it's awesome and I was
like dang it's a hunter potential if
your your kids are not gonna listen to
you as much as you want them to they
will listen Uncle Jake for some reason
uncle Jake will will take it home form I
listen to Uncle Jake I love those books
yeah I got taken out just reading the
books I'm like oh yeah
I gotta fix that oh here's something I
could do better yeah it's it's yeah it's
Uncle Jake Uncle Jake is who Uncle Jake
has good information
you think I'm everybody's uncle Jake
yeah and people will say like oh you
know your uncle Jake to me and I'm like
I am so not uncle Jake if I was a little
Jake I'd be so much cooler
Uncle Jake is my uncle Jay yeah yeah I'm
just a little warrior kid over here
trying to try to learn to try to get on
the path you know FLE that's the way it
is you and war your kid soap you can get
that Irish oats Irish Oaks ranch calm
speaking of warrior kids Aidan's making
soap on his farm and he wants you to
stay clean what if I go to my kids said
today like comment and subscribe
kids we are not something you know
oh so Instagram the estimate and then
one my kids it's like like comment and
subscribe
yeah that's going up there if I start
saying that you keep the joggers out
yeah we're already awake and organic tea
for some reason which is just great but
that's a good thing it's just I know it
just tastes good and it's good for you
yeah so these are all thing they just
sound kind of light-hearted compared to
your you know yeah your whole anyway
also yes you too by the way that's where
they stay that's where you can run into
these videos where this because my
daughter sometimes watch your little
youtube videos and that's what they'll
say like comment and subscribe just
repetitive they're so true like yeah I
mean the children I get it I get it
um yeah so jokes don't say that but we
do have a YouTube channel and you're
basically right now saying subscribe to
the YouTube channel if you want
and so what Jason says you should like
the YouTube channel you should like it
and then I'm over here saying you should
comment like comment and subscribe
yeah I don't know that you can like the
YouTube channel you like the video yes
which is a quote-unquote like but here's
the thing you like to YouTube channel
you like the YouTube channel that's a
matter of opinion right yeah you like it
you kind of neutral or you don't like it
kind of thing that's up to you you can
tell you don't like it if you want to
have fun you can go to the youtube
channel jockle
Podcast and you can look at the people
that attack the downvotes so they'll be
and you know we don't have many down
votes losses I guess cool yeah it's
crazy or whatever thumbs down people get
mad mad what good kind of Isis terrorist
who the 13 Isis and members that gave
this a down vote you will rot in hell so
thanks for having my back there
they also like that let like to let
everyone know the NECA looks jacked
whatever there's a video that was just
released was the most recent video you
just did that describe is the normal
face well the normal face overreaction
overreaction you you release the video
you are not in the video but people are
saying that they could feel that you
were jacked just for watching this so
yeah like a your college act
psychological warfare you can get that
on itunes google play mp3 platforms if
you think you might have a moment of
weakness in your day-to-day life press
play and you'll get pushed through that
moment weakness but jock oh by the way
by me yeah yeah and not pushed will say
spotted that's better yeah because some
people they're not in the mood to get
pushed pragmatically reasoned with yes
reason to it yes yeah a reason very good
also speaking of reason when you want to
improve your home gym maybe even your
commercial gym you know 25 minutes I
don't know go to on it calm / chuckle
get yourself more kettlebells like me
got the Stormtrooper one oh you're gonna
break out some Star Wars and nerd stuff
over here bro yeah you ready yes so
Jango Fett was the guy that they used
for they're like oh you're the perfect
warrior we're gonna make all the clones
based on you and I believe that his deal
he made with those people is like you're
gonna give me one of the clones back
that I'm gonna raise as my son who
turned out to be Boba Fett yes okay yeah
oh wait wait so you're - you're letting
me know because I messed that up I think
so I think Jade yeah
tuned you up in there on the last
podcast if you guys are talking about it
again yes
is there a their books for that no just
something that you kind of because your
closet nerd Jason oh hey I played
Dungeons & Dragons when I was in high
school yeah absolutely and I can be open
about it today I was horrified to tell
you when I was in high school I do the
Dragons or that got out but right now I
don't care you got all kinds of like
little nerd know science fiction nerdism
right yeah enjoy science fiction that's
a lot of fun there you go that's cool
my younger brother who's a tattoo artist
up in San Clemente he has a complete
stormtrooper costume so do it do you
that's alright oh by the way are you in
the five-o is it the five-o first
Vader's fist no so well mine is I got
the stormtrooper costume like Bono one
what's five-o first Vader's so there's
an orc there's its or something there's
yeah there's an organization that does a
lot of oh just like work for like
honesty cancer kids and stuff like that
and it's all these people that are Star
Wars villains and because they don't
make cop no one can make costumes
because it's all license so they have to
make them themselves and then you go
there and they'll validate it and say
okay you're good to go
your costume is good and then and I hope
I'm not screwing up the unit name but I
think it's the the five-o first Vader's
fist
I've never do that that's pretty cool
actually going deal one the one I have
is like I don't know if it's a licensed
costume or what there aren't any you
just it has to be so good that they're
like they'll validate it oh because
there's no such thing as a licensed
costume no for any for just make this
stuff yeah the ones that classic were
like a lot they were like well I bought
two of there's a Darth Vader one and a
stormtrooper they're like a few thousand
dollars yeah my brother's a thousand
dollars for well not just to have it
though that's the thing he was put off
for flex point right so I was making
these videos comic the hobbies of Darth
be I gotta go check those out those are
a really good video
so either that's the potential in those
videos by the way yeah you didn't get
you didn't get where you needed to get
well we were going I know Pete you're
like them like famous jiu-jitsu people
wouldn't you know like Jeff Glover
Keaney corny like these guys Ramos is
we're just living our life but Darth
Vader's here too yeah so like he's doing
this so he's going on dates you know
he's doing this anyway it turned out
kind of funny or whatever so there's one
where the stormtrooper was in it he
wanted his lawyer when he got arrested
for chopping his head off it was pretty
good yeah it's deep thumbs up he's like
he's like the ex-boyfriend of his date
or whatever so uh so Vader like chops
his head off uh-huh
so the next episode he gets arrested for
that his lawyers a stormtrooper oh so
that's why I love it yeah do you ever
see that one where they did like a cops
episode but it was troopers and they're
storm troopers and they show up to
Luke's aunt and uncle and it's really a
domestic dispute and they kill everybody
it's yeah there's a lot of fun to be had
with those guys for sure nonetheless I
got the kettlebell I got it from on it
and they got some good stuff on there
nanak calm that's yeah good spot
including Star Wars stuff I also got
some books Mikey and the dragon so Mike
and the Dragons Jason you were actually
maybe the third or fourth person to hear
me read Mikey and the Dragons and I did
it on the beach in Coronado to you and
iris I was so excited I couldn't believe
it but when you started rhyming and the
whole thing I'm like how did you do that
it's like he's still rhyming and it's
still going and this story is just
awesome yeah super stoked on Mikey and
the Dragons
it's how old are your kids eight and six
and what age group can it go down to
would you say I'd say probably three
yeah it can get young it's got very
beautiful pictures that are bright and
colorful there's so yeah and then the
story rhymes it's gonna make your kid
smarter and there's times where I was
when I was writing it you know they say
write in a certain level
but at the same time I put some words in
there that kids aren't gonna necessarily
know right away and so they need to look
them up or they need to learn them poise
is one of them I remember using the word
poise and I was thinking well most kids
won't know what poises and then I
thought to myself good now they can
learn a new word be smarter yeah that's
a good point that when you say where
does it go down to so three I would say
there my son is like - he was like just
before two and a half and I'd read a
more reading it to my daughter he's
there but he'll catch certain things you
know when there's like monsters ready to
bite he'll be you know like he'll know
certain stuff so as you kind of get
older you absorb more and more but yeah
if you're - yeah it looks for them -
there you go yeah all kids if your kids
are a little bit older you can get him
away the warrior kid you can get them
marks mission which is the second book
in that series and now we have book
three coming out the title of book 3 is
where there's a will and mark he gets
involved in some more situations but
luckily his uncle Jake is there to help
him out
I get so many pictures of kids doing
pull-ups working out studying they're
gonna be warrior kids so get that book
for your kids get that book for your
library get that book for your school
get that book for anyone that you know
that has kids you'll be thankful and
they will be thankful and they'll come
and thank you it in you know it's cool
going to wrestling tournaments yeah this
is pretty cool I've had kids that are
you know freshmen in high school so
they're 14 years old or whatever and
they're like hey I read warrior kid
that's why I wrestle yeah yeah think
about that so three years ago when it
came out the kid got it and now he's
wrestling yeah that's what I'm talking
about get you kids that kids will listen
Uncle Jake
discipline equals freedom Field Manual
if you want to know how to get after it
there you go you have to wonder you can
just get the Field Manual if you want
the audio it's on iTunes Amazon music
Google Play and
extreme ownership first book I wrote
with my brother Leif babban
and then that follow-on book is the
dichotomy of leadership which is takes
all those lessons and shows where you
can screw them up and then teach you how
to fix them dichotomy leadership both
those books me in life we wrote them
check them out and then we have ash law
in front leadership consultancy we solve
problems through leadership it's me it's
life Bevin it's JP - no it's Dave Burke
it's Flynn Cochran it's Mike Cirelli
it's Mike bimah and it is now also Jason
Gardner Jason is a - LAN Front he just
retired and this is what we are doing
he's already got gigs booked which is
awesome
Ashlin front comm if you need help with
leadership in your organization we will
help you that's what we do we have the
muster in 2019 twenty-three twenty-four
million Chicago 19 20 September in
Denver four and five December in Sydney
Australia every event we've done is
sold-out go to extreme ownership calm if
you want to come otherwise it's gonna be
sold out and you won't be able to come
and you'll be all mad and you'll be mad
at me
mmm-hmm and then someone said that it's
like when I went to Lollapalooza yeah
and I went and saw Rollins who I kinda
knew and I was like hey man can you get
us in and Rollins said it'd be easier to
sneak you into Fort Knox and I kind of
like was all hardcore like you kind of
forgot what it's like in the streets but
it wasn't up to him exactly now now I'm
the guy yep now I'm the guy that's gonna
be saying hey be easier to sneak you
into Fort Knox I gave you a heads up
you're big-time now so check that's that
EF online online interactive training
from echelon thought we needed to speak
to more
people and we don't have enough
instructors couldn't run enough monsters
each year so if you want to know what we
teach you want to get granular with it
check out EF online.com and finally we
have the EF overwatch which is where we
take guys that came from Special
Operations and combat aviation they have
massive amounts of experienced
leadership experience they understand
the principles we talk about we write
about that we teach they understand
those and they will bring them into your
company you can hire them to work and
help your organization when EF overwatch
comm is where you can make that happen
and if you want to keep this
conversation going which is a pretty
varied conversation we're talking about
star wars and sniper operations in a
joggers and DMD yeah I mean that's
pretty good spectrum you know you might
be that D&D old-school D&D player with
your multi-sided dice getting after it
and if you want to talk to us about that
we are on the interwebs we're on Twitter
we are on Instagram we are on the lot
EKKO is a deco Charles I am at Chaco
Willick Jason is that Jason n Gardner
Jason n Gardner and on Facebook Jason
dot and dot Gardner on Instagram and
Jason n Gardner on Twitter and you're
new to all three platforms no I've been
on Instagram to Facebook for a while
okay just new to Twitter new to Twitter
have you ever checked out Twitter before
no it's mayhem and then I heard I'm
gonna have to be Karen oh I heard no
don't like you do have to be careful
yeah and you kind of don't but it's
weird but then I found out like they
were talking about maybe with sam harris
and he was talking about there's
legitimate there's Russian people
Russian BOTS it's also funny they're
sitting there just trolling they're just
trying to create mayhem and so we don't
have a lot of man to be quite honest
with you there's not a lot of mayhem
but at me for whatever reason but
everyone's pretty cool and it's it's
I've gotten a lot out of it out of
Twitter out of Instagram out of Facebook
people giving me information
recommending books
I'm from the book recommendations cuz
I'm pretty much exhausting my personal
knowledge of books right now and so
right now I'm getting so many good books
from troopers out there better letting
me know what's up
so echo anything else any other Star
Wars comment well you know nah for right
now no but now that we know that you
know we chase on has the knowledge mm
maybe later but yes for now thanks for
thanks for and Jason we'll continue this
conversation you know next podcast
anything else any closing comments I'm
really excited to be on the podcast I
just want to tell my wife iris that
she's amazing and made my life so much
better by meeting her
my oldest son chase out proud I am of
him and storming for love you guys
looking forward to seeing you soon
awesome
and of course um we actually could not
do this podcast or even live the life
that we live if it wasn't for our people
in uniform around the world here at home
our military personnel police and law
enforcement firefighters paramedics and
EMTs correctional officers Border Patrol
all first responders out there thank you
for what you do every day so that we can
do what we do every day and to everyone
else that's listening until that next
podcast remember that advice that
Hrothgar gave Beowulf that you should
choose the eternal rewards not the
short-term ones and
keep it always in the back of your mind
that your piercing eye will dim and
darken and death will arrive to sweep
you away so until then keep getting out
there into the world and getting after
it and until next time this is Jason
gardener and echo and Jocko out